Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast über Forschung und Bildung.
Und ja, mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zur,
man mag es nicht glauben, 100.
Ausgabe dieser Reihe, die eine Weile auf sich hat warten lassen, weil es eine Pause gab.
Ich betreibe jetzt diesen Podcast alleine weiter. Ja, hat eine Weile gedauert,
bis ich hier mir darüber im Klaren war, wie ich das jetzt hier fortsetzen möchte.
Und ja, eigentlich möchte ich es so fortsetzen, wie ich es auch bisher gemacht habe.
Das heißt, es geht hier auch weiterhin um Wissenschaft, es geht um Forschung,
es geht um Bildung und all diese Themen werde mich allerdings,
denke ich mal, in der nächsten Zeit vor allem nicht nur, aber auch um viel,
was um Energie sich dreht, hier thematisieren.
Und da dachte ich mir, zur hundertsten Folge, die jetzt so eine Weile hat auf
sich warten lassen, nehme ich mir mal ein ganz besonderes Thema heraus und bin
nach Greifswald gefahren zum Max-Planck-Institut für Plasmaphysik,
einem der beiden Standorte dieses Instituts.
Und ja, da bin ich jetzt und begrüße erstmal meinen Gesprächspartner,
nämlich Thomas Klinger. Schönen guten Tag.
Ja, schönen guten Tag.
Ja, Sie sind ja hier der Leiter der, jetzt habe ich die Formulierung natürlich
wieder mal nicht parat, Stelleratordynamik und Transport. Das klingt ja ein bisschen speziell.
Wie Wissenschaft so ist, das ist der Name meines wissenschaftlichen Bereichs.
Das ist eine Aufgabe. Die andere Aufgabe ist, dass ich mich mit meinem ganzen
Team um den Wendelstein 7X Stellarator selber als solches technisch und vom
Betrieblichen her kümmere.
Also ich habe da zwei Hüte auf.
Ja, dieser Standort, das ist der Ort, wo der große Prototyp steht für Fusionsenergie
und nach der Stellarator-Technik, deswegen halt auch der Name.
Vielleicht schauen wir erstmal, was macht eigentlich das Max-Planck-Institut
für Plasmaphysik und speziell, was macht dieser Standort, worauf konzentriert man sich hier?
Naja, wir konzentrieren uns wirklich komplett auf den Stellarator.
Also wir haben nur dieses eine Thema.
Nur, das ist eine große, sehr komplexe Maschine, die auch unsere gesamte Aufmerksamkeit
sowohl technisch wie organisatorisch wie auch von der Wissenschaft her beansprucht.
Insofern brauchen wir da gar nicht groß drüber philosophieren,
was unser Schwerpunkt ist. Unser Schwerpunkt ist alles, was den technischen
und wissenschaftlichen Betrieb dieser wissenschaftlichen Großanlage betrifft.
Und groß ist sie ja auch, also ich glaube der Standort hier hat in etwa genauso
viele forschende Mitarbeiter wie in Garching an dem Hauptstandort,
größtenordnungsmäßig, ein bisschen weniger Verwaltung.
Nein, also es gibt auch in Garching noch etwas mehr technische Infrastruktur
und noch ein paar andere Aktivitäten, die für die Fusion wichtig sind,
die aber nicht direkt an die Maschinen gebunden sind.
Das sind so technologische Entwicklungen, sehr große Materialforschung,
die wir in Garching haben.
Also das ist einfach etwas anders aufgestellt, aber wir haben eben dort Themen,
die für uns hier in Greifswald mindestens genauso wichtig sind wie in Garching.
Aber die in Garching aus Strukturgründen angesiedelt sind.
Genau, aber dafür ist also sozusagen Greifswald dann im Wesentlichen gegründet
worden, um dieses Thema voranzubringen.
Da wird ja auch schon eine ganze Weile dran gearbeitet. Ich glaube,
den Standort gibt es hier seit 2010 ungefähr. Stimmt das?
Nein.
Nein? Bisschen länger noch?
Die Gründung des Standortes ist 1996 erfolgt, der Gründungsbeschluss.
Dann ist das Gebäude, in dem wir hier sitzen,
2000 in Betrieb genommen worden und seit
1996 aufwärts ist die Realisierung dieser Maschine die Hauptaufgabe gewesen
und jetzt der Betrieb und Weiterentwicklung, Weiterausbau der Maschine.
Ja, wie sind Sie denn selber so zur Physik gekommen?
Wird mich ja mal interessieren, wie nimmt man denn da Fahrt auf in die Richtung?
Also in der Schule habe ich schon ganz gerne Physik gemacht.
Es war jetzt nicht so, dass das meine einzige Leidenschaft war.
Es war so ein bisschen undefiniert, wie das immer so ist. Ein bisschen die Berufsentscheidung,
das ist dann auch so ein mehrandreierender Prozess.
Eigentlich wollte ich mal zur See fahren, bin dann auch anderthalb Jahre zur See gefahren.
Ach echt?
Und da hatte ich die Nase voll.
Seekrank geworden?
Nee, ich werde nicht seekrank.
Okay, was war da nicht so schön?
Es war sehr kalt.
Und habe mich dann entschieden, doch zu studieren. Also das heißt,
ja, tatsächlich etwas zu studieren und habe mich dann für Physik entschieden.
In dem Sinne etwas zufällig.
Und dann war das einfach so?
Ja, ich hätte auch Ingenieurwissenschaften machen können, aber mein Bruder ist
Ingenieur und man macht niemals das, was der ältere Bruder macht.
Okay, aber wie kommt man dann so zur Plasmaphysik im Speziellen?
Da bin ich auch so reingeschlittert.
Einfach Zufall?
Ja, ich hätte auch elementarteilig ein Physiker werden können,
war ich fast, also durch schlichte Zufälle, auf die ich jetzt gar nicht eingehen will.
Okay.
Bin ich dann einmal umgeschwenkt und dann in der Plasmaphysik erstmal gelandet
und über die Plasmaphysik dann in die Fusionsforschung so hinein geglitten.
Und wann sind Sie dann hier dazugekommen?
Nach Greifswald bin ich 1999 gekommen. Da hatte ich eine Professur an der Universität
bekommen für Plasmaphysik.
Plasmaphysik ist ja größer als Fusionsforschung. Das ist ja ein ganzes Gebiet.
Und habe dann hier angefangen, eine Arbeitsgruppe aufzubauen,
die sich mit Grundlagenaspekten der Plasmaphysik beschäftigt hat.
Und kurz danach, also schon kurz danach, ich hatte sowieso schon von früher
her Kontakte zum Max-Planck-Institut und nach zwei Jahren wurde ich da einfach
vom Max-Planck-Institut gefragt, ob ich hier nicht mitmachen will.
Und so kam es dann einfach.
Ja.
Ich will jetzt mal so ein bisschen auf die Kernfusion selbst gehen.
Das ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man davon reden kann, dass es ein relativ neues Feld der Physik ist.
Also seit wann...
Weiß man denn, wie Kernfusion abläuft?
Also wodurch hat sich sozusagen das Wissen gebildet, dass Kernfusion stattfindet,
möglich ist und wie es in der Sonne abläuft?
Ja, ich bin nur kein Kernphysiker, insofern bleibe ich da mal ein bisschen an
der Oberfläche, so in der Physikhistorie.
Das Ganze geht ja zurück auf das Verständnis der Struktur der Atomkerne überhaupt.
Kann man so hier Namen wie Ernest Rutherford nennen, der erstmal festgestellt
hat, dass so ein Atomkern super klein ist und dass furchtbar viel Platz ist zwischen der Materie.
Das war so der erste Schritt, die Rutherfordischen Streuversuche,
damit fing das so langsam an.
Natürlich war ein großer Schritt, als festgestellt wurde, dass man,
also rein aus Zufall festgestellt wurde, dass man Kerne durch Beschuss,
durch Neutronenbeschuss spalten kann.
Und da war der Umkehrschluss natürlich sehr naheliegend. Alles,
was man spalten kann, kann man auch wieder zusammenfügen.
Und man hat dann relativ schnell dann schon vermutet, dass da auch der umgekehrte
Prozess geht. Warum nicht?
Also da gibt es überhaupt kein physikalisches Argument, dass der Rückwärtsgang nicht geht.
Und hat sich diese Sache auch angeschaut, erstmal so rein spekulativ,
das war erstmal ein bisschen schwieriger zu erkunden.
Das Ganze war auch verbunden mit der großen offenen Frage, wie eigentlich die Sterne funktionieren.
Denn Kernspaltung fiel aus, dass die über Kernspaltung ihre Energie erzeugen.
Das konnte man einfach durch ein paar quantitative Rechnungen,
durch ein paar Zahlen konnte man das relativ schnell ausschließen,
dass das der Fall ist, chemische Verbrennung auch, kommt viel zu wenig bei rum.
Und dann blieb bloß noch die Fusion übrig. Das war dann so die Hypothese.
Und ich denke, das war Hans Beete, der der Sache dann wirklich auf die Spur
gekommen ist. Dann gab es noch etliche, die dann verwickelt waren,
später auch Weizsäcker.
George Gamow hat auch eine wichtige Rolle gespielt. Der russisch-amerikanische
Wissenschaftler, der oft schon vergessen ist.
Und da mussten eben viele Puzzlesteine zusammengesetzt werden,
bis man dann diese Zyklen,
diese Prozesse, diese Prozessketten, die im Inneren der Sterne stattfinden,
bis man die mal so hypothetisch aufstellen konnte und auf der Basis dieser Hypothese
dann eben Rechnungen durchführt, die wie üblich in der Physik mit Beobachtungen abgleicht.
Mit Plausibilitäten, mit Stabilität, mit Massebetrachtung und so weiter und
so weiter, ob das alles zusammenpasst.
Und das war im Prinzip dann überhaupt erstmal die Realisierung,
dass es eben diesen Elementarprozess gibt, also eben analog zur Kernspaltung,
entlang der Elemente, dass man eben die schweren Elemente spalten kann,
dass man eben leichtere Elemente auch miteinander fusionieren kann.
Und man kann alle möglichen Elemente miteinander fusionieren.
Das ist völlig beliebig, also nicht völlig beliebig, Aber man hat ein weites
Feld von leichten Elementen, die man miteinander fusionieren kann.
Und das hängt eben sehr von den Bedingungen
ab und von den entsprechenden Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die Fusion ab.
Gut, und damit war das einfach erstmal ein Gesamtbild, was man sich da von den
Kernkonstituenten gesetzt hat.
Dann kam später noch die ganze Elementarteilchengeschichte dazu,
wo man eben festgestellt hatte, dass diese Konstituenten, Protonen und Neutronen,
dass die dann nochmal weitere Konstituenten haben, also nochmal weiter innerlich
zusammengesetzt werden.
Das war dann wieder eine ganz andere Thematik.
Die damit nicht so direkt verbunden ist, indirekt natürlich schon.
Gut, also das heißt, die Moral von der Geschichte hat eigentlich angefangen
mit dem Elementarprozess,
aber dann direkt auch die Übertragung auf den Prozess der Sterne und damit eben
stellvertretend für die Sterne unserer Sonne abgebildet, weil das war bis dahin
noch, wusste man einfach nicht, wie es geht.
Und wodurch wird klar, dass dabei bei einer Kernfusion Energie freigesetzt wird?
Das ist eben halt ein kernphysikalischer Aspekt dabei.
Das ist der sogenannte Massendefekt, also indem man die Erkenntnis,
dass Masse und Energie letztlich das gleiche ist, das ist eben halt auch wieder
verbunden mit Einsteins Relativitätstheorie, das ist die berühmte E gleich mc²,
also Masse und Energie ist einfach das gleiche und Energie lässt sich in Masse
und Masse in Energie umwandeln.
Das hat dabei eine Rolle gespielt und die Differenz der Bindungsenergie der
Kerne, die sich dann letztlich in Masse manifestiert,
die wird einfach in kinetische Energie umgesetzt. Das ergibt sich einfach aus der Logik des Ganzen.
Okay. Und seit wann gibt es jetzt die Überlegung, das zur Energiegewinnung zu nutzen?
Das ging letztlich in den 50er Jahren los.
Also die Kernspaltung ist ja relativ früh schon erkannt worden als eine Energiequelle
und zwar letztlich in zwei Richtungen.
Also einerseits natürlich sehr prominent als Bombe.
Das heißt, da gab es ja diese ganze Oppenheimer-Geschichte, das Wettrennen um die Bombe.
Das ist ja letztlich auch einfach eine Freisetzung von sehr großen Mengen Energie, eine Vulgo-Bombe.
Aber gleich parallel dazu hat man sich auch sofort dafür interessiert aus der Kernspaltung,
Antriebsaggregate für U-Boote etwa zu entwickeln U-Boote müssen einfach lange tauchen können,
und Elektromotoren da ist die Batterie schnell alle also das hat die Tauchdauer
dann beschränkt deshalb war es eben halt sehr attraktiv einfach eine ja nicht ja also nicht.
Einen Nicht-Verbrennermotor zu haben, der aber sehr lange läuft.
Also deshalb ist das sehr früh schon vorangetrieben worden.
Also sozusagen das Atom-U-Boot war so der Motivator dafür, den Leichtwasserreaktor zu entwickeln.
Und das lief dann so letztlich auch parallel mit der Bombenentwicklung, also Reaktor und Bombe.
Das ist am Ende vom Prozess her bei der Spaltung nicht so gut voneinander zu trennen.
Und das war aber sehr stark getrieben eben von diesem Rüstungsaspekt und von
diesem militärischen Aspekt.
Deshalb waren da einfach sehr viele Ressourcen, auch sehr viel Dringlichkeit,
denn wir kennen ja alle diese Geschichte.
Die war bei der Fusion erstmal nicht. Trotzdem war klar, dass es auch ein Prozess
ist, der Energieüberschuss, sogar noch effizienter Energieüberschuss produziert.
Hatte aber eben erstmal nicht diesen militärischen Aspekt, als später mit der
Wasserstoffbombe ist der so reingekommen, weil es ja sozusagen so ein Nachzünder,
den man dann noch auf die Atombombe raufsetzt.
Die funktioniert ja nicht super für sich.
Aber auch so im Rahmen dessen ist dann so klargekommen, naja,
jetzt muss man sich das auch mal angucken, ob man daraus nicht ein Kraftwerk
bauen kann. Und das fing so in den 50er Jahren an.
Und also so nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg eigentlich ernsthaft.
Und da hat anfänglich hat es da viel Euphorie gegeben.
So in dem Sinne, das dürfte ja eigentlich gar nicht so schwer sein.
Und aus der Zeit kommen auch noch sehr optimistische Vorhersagen.
Das war sowieso so eine Euphorie, wenn Sie da in die 50er Jahre gehen.
In allen Feldern eigentlich.
Ja, auch eine große nukleare Euphorie. Sowohl Spaltung wie auch Fusion.
Also das heißt, das war so die Zukunft. Und das war auch fast wie ein Heilsbringer.
Das Ganze wurde so behandelt.
Unendliche Energie.
Ja, und keine Nachteile, nur Vorteile und Energie für jeden.
Also wie gesagt, das war eine euphorische Zeit.
Aus solchen Euphorien heraus kommen natürlich auch manchmal etwas überoptimistische Vorhersagen.
Und das ist dann auch der Geburtsort für den ältesten Fusionswitz.
Das ist eine Energie, die immer 50 Jahre entfernt ist.
Denn man hat sich ja damals schon zu solchen recht optimistischen Vorhersagen
treiben lassen, dass man sagt, innerhalb dieses Jahrtausends schaffen wir es auf jeden Fall.
Also 1950, das heißt innerhalb des 20. Jahrhunderts.
Da gab es eben einige Warne, die gesagt haben, das sieht nicht so einfach aus.
Und dieses Jahrhundert können wir irgendwie vergessen, das wird nichts.
Aber auf die hat keiner gehört.
Die Presse hat nur die Optimisten zitiert. Und damit ist dann dieses Etikett
dann gleich kleben geblieben, denn wir haben es ja immer noch nicht.
Das Jahrtausend ist vorbei, wir haben es immer noch nicht und da müssen wir
uns immer wieder anhören, was ist denn das für eine traurige Geschichte.
Und wenn man uns jetzt fragt, sagen wir auch zweite Hälfte dieses Jahrhunderts
und dann hört sich das halt nach so einem Moving Target an,
wie nach der berühmten Möhre, der der Esel die ganze Zeit hinterherläuft,
obwohl sie eben halt an einer Angel vorhin gehalten wird und der Esel realisiert
das nicht, so eselig sind wir gar nicht.
Aber inzwischen hat man einfach besser verstanden, was das für eine harte Nuss ist.
Die da geknackt werden muss und auch, was die Bedingungen sind,
die man schaffen muss, um diesen Elementarprozess wirklich effizient auf die Beine zu stellen.
Denn Fusion an sich zu machen, ist ein Elementarprozess. Das ist total einfach.
Das kann jeder im Keller machen.
Da gibt es Wikipedia-Artikel, wie man Fusion macht, braucht man echt nicht viel.
Braucht man ein Hochspannungsnetzgerät, eine Pumpe, fertig. Das ist wirklich nicht viel.
Und was hat man dann fusioniert im Keller?
Da hat man dort fusioniert.
Okay.
Dann kommen ein paar Neutronen raus, kann man zählen. 3, 4, 5, 10,
100, paar tausend, nützt aber nichts nicht, weil das, was man in Energie reinsteckt,
um das zu machen, ist eben halt mehrere Größenordnungen über dem,
was man aus den Neutronen rausholen könnte.
Und das ist ja nicht so ganz die Idee dabei.
Nee, also negative Energieverluste erzeugen, das ist ja nicht so schwierig.
Aber einen Energieüberschuss zu erzeugen, dafür braucht man eben viele Fusionsprozesse.
Und einer hohen Dichte, das heißt viel pro Sekunde und Kubikmeter.
Okay, jetzt stellt sich natürlich dann die Frage, wie hat man sich auf den Weg
begeben, darüber nachzudenken, wie man dieses Missverhältnis aufheben kann?
Also wie baut man dann ein Fusionssystem, wo dann am Ende mehr Energie bei rauskommt,
als man reingesteckt hat? Weil das ja dann letzten Endes ist das Ziel.
Wo fängt man da an?
Also wenn wir jetzt von der Magnetfusion reden, jetzt müssen wir eine Abzweigung nehmen.
Das ist ja das Geschäft, was wir hier betreiben, auch das Geschäft,
mit dem ich mich jetzt ja lange beschäftige und mehr oder weniger gut auskenne.
Da ist es definitiv ein Volumeneffekt. Also das heißt, man braucht Volumen.
Warum? Die Fusion, also dieser Elementarprozess, der passiert ja im Volumen.
Also wir haben ein Gas, ein heißes Gas, also eine Anzahl von Atomen da drin,
von Kernen da drin und die haben eine bestimmte Wahrscheinlichkeit miteinander zu fusionieren.
Und wenn man halt viele nimmt bei einer gegebenen Dichte, die Dichte ist nicht
beliebig, die muss man an einem richtigen Punkt einstellen und dann braucht
man für viele einfach Volumen,
um genügend Einzelelementarprozesse, sozusagen Verbrennungsprozesse zu haben,
was dann aufsummiert Energie ergibt.
Die Verluste, die unvermeidlichen Verluste, die gehen alle durch die Oberfläche.
Verluste zur Wand. Denn die Wand ist kalt und das Gas, dieses Plasma muss heiß sein.
Dieser Wärmeverlust, der drückt dann die Temperatur dieses Gases, dieses Plasmas runter.
Und wenn die Temperatur runtergedrückt wird, wird die Fusionswahrscheinlichkeit immer kleiner.
Also muss man dafür sorgen.
Dass es heiß bleibt.
Also es muss heiß sein, es muss eine bestimmte Dichte haben.
Und dieses Heißsein, das erfordert eben Wärmeisolation.
Denn es ist umgeben von einer kalten Wand, die ist wie so eine Kühlfläche.
Dagegen muss das Wärme isoliert werden. Und die Isolation ist natürlich an der Oberfläche.
Das heißt also, das Volumen zur Oberfläche-Verhältnis ist kritisch.
In anderen Worten, so eine Tabletop-Fusionsanlage, wie man sie sich in den 50er Jahren überlegt hat,
wie es so nach den Erkenntnissen zu der Zeit aussah, dass man es so machen könnte,
Das mussten wir bitter lernen, die gibt es nicht.
Dazu sind die Verluste zu groß. Unvermeidliche Verluste.
Denn die Bedingungen auf der Sonne sind ja nun mal ganz andere.
Da gibt es sehr viel davon. Es ist alles sehr dicht, es ist alles sehr heiß.
Und obwohl die natürlich eine große Oberfläche hat und es auch ziemlich kalt
drumherum ist, ist die Hitze und die Dichte innerhalb der Sonne so extrem,
dass Fusion permanent stattfindet.
Ja, die Sonne ist erstmal groß. Das hilft.
Dann hat sie bezogen auf das Plasma einen nochmal deutlich, deutlich extremeren Materiezustand.
Vor allem die Dichte ist erheblich höher als das, was wir mit vernünftigen Aufwand
hier auf der Erde herstellen können, zumindest so als kontinuierliches System.
Wir reden im Zentrum der Sonne, wo die Fusion stattfindet von einer Materiedichte,
die etwa Faktor 1000 höher ist als unsere Festkörperdichte, unsere konsensierte
Materie, die uns umgibt.
Also unsere ganze Welt besteht ja im Großen und Ganzen aus kondensierter Materie.
Also Steine, Wasser, letztlich auch Luft kann man da gut dazu zählen.
Nicht ganz, das ist ein Übergang.
Aber das ist ja alles tausendmal Dichte. Also das heißt wirklich ordentlich
hohe Dichte und dann eben ordentlich hohe Temperatur.
Und dann nimmt sich die Sonne einfach das Volumen und Zeit. Das heißt man wartet.
Die Sonne kann warten.
Und diese Kombination aus all den Dingen, die ist nicht gut. denn,
Solchen Materiezustand können wir auf der Erde nicht mit vernünftigem Aufwand erzeugen.
Und wenn ja annähernd für Nanosekunden, also für winzige Bruchteile von Sekunden,
das ist das, was man in der Laserfusion versucht.
Da nähert man sich tatsächlich dem Materiezustand im Zentrum der Sonne so halbwegs
an und versucht also auf die Art und Weise das zu machen.
Das ist aber offenbar eben halt ein Kurzzeitprozess. Also ein ganz kurzer Blitz, der so erzeugt wird.
Also für einen Bruchteil in der Sekunde erzeugt man mal ein tatsächlich sonnenartiges Plasma.
Minisonne.
Die berühmte Minisonne.
Darüber will ich hier auch gar nicht viel referieren. Das ist nicht unser Geschäft.
Das ist ein komplett anderer Zweig der Plasmaphysik, mit dem ich mich nicht
nur peripher beschäftige, weil er so anders ist.
Den gibt es auch. Das ist der andere Pfad.
Nebenbei gesagt, der ist auch schwierig. Da darf man sich nichts vormachen,
dass man sagt, das ist die Abkürzung zu der Fusionsenergie auf Erden.
Das ist auch ein sehr hartes Brot aus anderen Gründen. Aber wir wollen uns da
nicht so sehr verheddern jetzt.
Wir machen eben halt, die magnetische Fusion, die wir hier in Greifswald machen,
basiert auf sehr dünnen Plasmen.
Nicht sehr dünnen, sehr heißen Plasmen. Aber dieses sehr dünnen ist entscheidend.
Also dünn im Sinne von nicht so dicht?
Ja, Materiedichte. Also dünn, muss man es in eine Perspektive zu setzen.
Wir reden etwa von Faktor 100.000 dünner als die Luft, die wir atmen.
Also wirklich dünne Luft.
Also wenn man so in die Atmosphäre nach oben reißt, irgendwann wird die Duft halt immer dünnert.
Nicht so, das heißt wir sind dann irgendwo in der Jonsphäre oder sowas,
also schon ganz oben in unserer Atmosphäre, wo bloß Reste davon sind.
Das heißt, es ist sehr dünne Materie, die kann man mit einem Vertretbaren Aufwand sehr heiß bekommen.
Hat den Vorteil, wenn man das miteinander multipliziert und mit den Faktoren
versieht, die man da vorschreiben muss, dann kriegt man einen Druck.
Und dieser Druck, das sind so,
Drei bis fünf Bar als Gasdruck.
Also so Fahrradreifen.
Fahrradreifen, das hört sich so an, als könnte man das hinbekommen. Nicht so technisch.
Bei der Sonne reden wir von Gigapascal, also von ganz anderen Drücken.
Also das sind einfach diese typischen astronomischen Dimensionen,
die also nur bei der Sonne durch Gravitation zusammengehalten werden können,
weil die Sonne einfach so riesig ist.
Also einen Gravitationseinschluss kann man auf der Erde nicht machen.
Aber wir brauchen auf jeden Fall diesen Plasmazustand dieses Gases,
auch wenn es nicht so dicht ist.
Und man muss dem entgegenarbeiten, dass es nicht all die Wärme,
die es braucht, um das aufrecht zu erhalten, sofort wieder verliert.
Also muss man es in irgendeiner Form einpacken, einschließen,
bei sich behalten, um sozusagen einen kontrollierten Ort zu haben,
in dem eine Fusionsreaktion dann mehr oder weniger von alleine stattfindet.
Das ist quasi ein Gefäß. Aber es ist ein immaterielles Gefäß.
Denn auch dieses dünne Gas wohnt erstmal in einem Stahlgefäß.
Und das Stahlgefäß ist halt kalt, hat Raumtemperatur.
Und man muss dann noch für die Isolation noch ein immaterielles Gefäß schaffen,
was dieses heiße Gas von den Wänden trennt.
Das ist eben diese Wärmeisolationsaufgabe. Ansonsten hätte es einfach durch
den Wärmekontakt, hätte das Gas Wandtemperatur. Und die reicht nicht.
Dann passiert keine Fusion, sondern für Fusion braucht man tatsächlich exotisch hohe Temperaturen.
Wir reden da so von 100, Größenordnung 100 Millionen Grad, was sich ganz erschreckend anhört.
Man muss da aber im Kopf behalten, wir reden von einem sehr dünnen Gas.
Und unser Temperaturbegriff, der ist ja ganz stark geprägt von der kondensierten
Materie, also von der Tasse Tee oder von einer Herdplatte, das ist alles feste Materie.
Und da sind 100 Grad oder 1000 Grad schon alles sehr heiß.
1000 Grad ist schon verflixt heiß, also nicht unvorstellbar heiß,
aber schon sehr, sehr heiß.
Wenn wir von Lava reden, dann sind es um 2000 Grad und das ist so der Erfahrungsbereich
und da hört sich 100 Millionen Grad natürlich irre an, ist es aber nicht,
weil wir von einem sehr dünnen Gas reden.
Und Temperatur ist ja in der Physik nichts anderes als eine Begrifflichkeit für Geschwindigkeit.
Die Geschwindigkeit der Atome.
Die Geschwindigkeit der Atome, der individuellen Atome in einem statistischen Mittel.
Und wir müssen einfach nur diese Atome auf dieses Tempo bringen und beim dünnen
Gas ist das sehr gut machbar.
Allerdings beim Kontakt wieder mit der festen Materie, mit dem Kessel,
würde man dieses Gas einfach nicht viel mehr als auf Raumtemperatur bekommen.
Das heißt, man braucht eine Isolation und das ist ein immaterieller zweite Lager,
ein zweites Gefäß. und das sind die berühmten Magnetfelder.
Die das einschließen, das Plasma, damit es sozusagen bei sich bleibt und sie wärmen nicht ab.
Man muss sich das wie ein Gefäß vorstellen. Wie so eine zweite Wand.
Die zwischen der materiellen Wand, der Stahlwand, und dem eigentlichen Plasma
ist, was man heiß machen möchte.
Kein Styropor ist nichts Materielles, sondern eine immaterielle Isolation.
Aber es ist de facto eine weitere Lage, ein weiteres Gefäß, was man dazwischen packt.
Und die Form dieses Gefäßes, diese Form dieses Immateriellen,
dieses magnetischen Gefäßes, die ist sehr wichtig.
Klingt jetzt erstmal nach einem Rohr. Ja. Also man hat so einen außen umschließenden
Mantel und dann soll das Plasma in der Mitte sein und durch Magnete hält man
es sozusagen von dieser eigentlichen Wand des Rohres fern.
Ja, also erstmal, also ein Rohr ist erstmal schon mal ein guter Ansatz.
Damit haben wir auch angefangen. Erstmal mit einem geraden Rohr.
Da hat man festgestellt, ein gerades Rohr hat natürlich zwei Enden.
Wie die Wurst?
Ja, die Wurst, so zwei Enden. Nur die Wurst hat zwei. Und an diesen Enden,
das sind automatische Verlustflächen.
Denn da steht dieses immaterielle Gefäß einfach in Kontakt wieder mit der kalten Wand.
Das heißt, man ist gut beraten, dieses Rohr zu einem Ring zu biegen.
Denn damit kann man die Magnetfeldlinien schließen.
Aber man könnte doch auch die Magnetfelder an den Seiten so ausrichten,
dass es auch an da nicht rankommt.
Ja, hat man auch versucht. Also man hat das so zugequetscht.
Das sind sogenannte Spiegelmaschinen, um diesen Kontakt mit der Wand zu verringern.
Das hat auch was gebracht, aber es war am Ende dann doch nicht genug.
Er hatte doch zu große Verluste.
Denn das ist einfach ein nicht verhinderbarer Kontakt zwischen diesem Magnetfeld und der Wand.
Da stoßen die Magnetfeldlinien auf die Wand und das bedeutet einen Kontakt.
Das ist wie eine Lücke in der Isolation, wie ein Loch in der Isolation,
was man bei seinem Haus auch gar nicht haben würde.
Und damit dieser Ansatz dann sozusagen kein Ende findet, hat man die Enden einfach
weggelassen und das Ganze ist dann im Ring gemacht.
Wenn eine Wurst kein N haben soll, dann biegt man die Wurst zu einem Wurstring.
Und dann hat man einen Wurstring.
Also insofern wollen wir nicht zu sehr mit solchen kulinarischen Vergleichen
uns damit zufriedenstellen.
Aber es hilft ein bisschen die Vorstellung zu machen. Es wird oft vom Donut
gesprochen, also das ist am Ende egal.
Sagen wir korrekt Torus.
Ja, Torus ist der mathematische Begriff. Der ist nicht ganz so alltäglich.
Aber es ist ein Torus, also es ist ein Ring. ein Torrüssel, der vom Magnetfeld erfüllt ist.
So, das ist dann der erste Punkt. Also da waren wir auch schon 1950.
Wenn die magnetischen Feldlinien dieses Rings, wenn man die einfach so belässt,
also das Rohr zu einem Ring biegt und das so belässt,
dann muss man sich mit einem unangenehmen Effekt auseinandersetzen,
der so ein Klassiker der Plasmaphysik ist.
Durch die Tatsache, dass die Magnetfeldlinien dann ja gekrümmt sind,
nicht mehr gerade, sondern gekrümmt,
und dass sie durch das Zusammenbiegen auf der Innenseite enger liegen als außen, auch sehr logisch,
bekommen also einerseits eine Krümmung der Magnetfeldlinie, logisch,
zweitens auch noch eine Inhomogenität, also eine Veränderung des Magnetfeldes.
Ungleichförmigkeit.
Ungleichförmigkeit. Und beides führt dazu, dass diese geladenen Teilchen einem
in in der radialen Richtung, das heißt also senkrecht zu den Magnetfeldlinien rausdriften.
Also diese Teilchen machen eine Gyrationsbewegung in die Magnetfeldlinien herum
und sehen, während dieser Gyrationsbewegung einerseits die Krümmung,
andererseits die Inhomogenität und jedes Mal kriegen sie sozusagen so einen
kleinen Versatz unserer Unwucht.
Das ist wie so eine Fliehkraft, kann man sich so fast vorstellen.
Auf jeden Fall beginnen die radial sich rauszubewegen, also senkrecht zu dem
Magnetfeld in sich rauszubewegen. Und das hört sich schon nicht gut an.
Weil damit transportieren sie Teilchen, aber auch die Wärme,
die sie tragen, nach außen. Damit hat man wieder den Wärmeverlust.
Das wurde schon sehr früh erkannt. Und ganz einfacher Trick,
den man da macht, man verdreht diese magnetischen Feldlinien,
um dieses Rausdriften zu kompensieren, so als grobes Bild.
Das heißt, sie müssen nicht nur regnförmig sein, sie müssen auch in sich verdreht sein.
Und dieses Verdrehen, das muss man eben halt in den Magnetfeldern noch zusätzlich erreichen.
Denn das Magnetfeld an sich kann man erstmal mit einem Satz von Magneten erzeugen,
von Elektromagneten erzeugen, die man also einfach ringförmig aufstellt und
dann hat man ein ringförmiges Magnetfeld.
Das hat aber noch nicht die Verdrehung.
Für die Verdrehung muss man sozusagen diese Spulen, die ja letztlich dieses
Magnetfeld erzeugen, selbst auch nochmal ihrer Gleichförmigkeit berauben.
Das ist eine Möglichkeit, entweder indem man einen weiteren zusätzlichen Spulensatz
spendiert, der die Verdrehung übernimmt, nicht so eine Kombi.
Oder wie beim Wendelstein, indem man diese Spulen nicht mehr einfach belässt,
sondern diese Verdrehung in die Spulen hineingießt.
Und das heißt, das Verdrehen der magnetischen Feldlinien durch die Formgebung der Spulen erreicht.
Das ist das Stellaratorprinzip dabei.
Genau und damit sind wir sozusagen bei dem Prinzip der Installation,
die jetzt hier in Greifswald gebaut worden ist, angekommen.
Das ist aber nicht der einzige Ansatz, den man jetzt verfolgt hat.
Es gibt ja noch mit Tokamak noch ein zweites Prinzip, was ähnlich funktioniert, aber anders.
Ja, das schließt genau an das an, was wir gerade gesagt haben.
Diese Verdrehung der magnetischen Feldlinien kann man auch erreichen,
indem man einen sehr starken Strom in das Plasma hineinbringt.
Und dieser starke strom erzeugt für sich wiederum ein magnetfeld und das magnetfeld
was dieser starke strom erzeugt kombiniert mit dem magnetfeld was der strom
in den spulen erzeugt erzeugt dieses verdrehte magnetfeld das ist das tokamark prinzip.
Also zwei ansätze sozusagen um dasselbe ziel.
Zu erreichen ja und hat eben ja die,
Spezialität, dass man eben halt einen Strom in das Plasma rein zaubern muss.
Ja. Also abgesehen von dem, also wenn wir von Wendelstein sprechen,
das ist der Name des Projektes hier, also der Name dieses,
Forschungsreaktors, der hier gebaut wird. Ich glaube, der Grund ist ein Berg,
Wendelstein ist ein Berg in Bayerischen Alpen.
In Bayerischen Alpen.
Weil das so ein hohes Ziel ist, was man hier erreichen will.
Ach, das hat historische Gründe, diese Benennung nach Bergen.
Geht zuletzt zurück auf die allerersten Stelleratoren, die an der Princeton
University gebaut wurden, von dem US-amerikanischen Astrophysiker Lyman Spitzer.
Der war halt begeisterter Bergsteiger und mochte sehr die Alpen und hatte seine
Maschine oder sein Projekt, hatte den Kennnamen Project Matterhorn.
Und das war die Inspiration hier für die deutsche Aktivität auf dem gleichen Gebiet.
Also als man so gesehen hat, was da in Princeton getrieben wurde,
wollte man sich da in dieser Richtung auch engagieren.
Und das war die Inspiration dafür, das nach einem anderen Berg zu benennen,
also nach einem bayerischen Berg, weil es da die Aktivität in Garching gestartet
war. Und da hatte man den Wendelstein genommen.
Erstens, weil das ein allgemein bekannter Berg dort ist.
Das ist ein Ausflugsberg und ich habe mir auch mal sagen lassen,
dass der Fußweg da hoch auf solchen Serpentinen, solchen sehr gewendelten Faden
geht, weshalb er vielleicht auch so heißt, aber ich weiß es nicht,
vielleicht ist das auch irreführend.
Und das war so ein weiteres Element, was eben mit dieser Geometrie der Magnete
verbunden ein inspirierendes Element war.
Am Ende ist es ein Wendelstein geworden und dieser Name ist eben seit den 60er
Jahren beibehalten worden und hat dann auch hier eine Heimat gefunden.
Genau und es gibt es in mehreren Versionen, jetzt sind wir irgendwie bei Version
7. Das X, was da noch dabei ist.
Ist auch alles alles historie also es gab ein
wendelstein 1 es gab ein wendelstein 1 a 1 b
es gab ein 2 2 a 2 b 3 4 5 und 6 sind nie gebaut worden gab es ein wendelstein
7 dann gab es ein wendelstein 7 a dann gab es ein wendelstein 7 as und dann
gibt es jetzt hier den wendelstein 7x als neueste version,
Und warum man bei sieben kleben geblieben ist, können Sie die Frage,
hätte ich auch sieben, acht, neun, zehn oder sowas machen.
Das sind immer so ein bisschen Geschmackssachen. Am Ende ist Wendelstein 7 denn
so in den späten 70er Jahren auch zu einer Marke geworden.
Und da wollte man diese Marke nicht mehr ändern.
Okay, Branding.
Auch in der Physik gibt es Marketing.
Marketing und beliebte Namespaces, hier sind es dann halt einfach die Berge.
Aber ich habe das jetzt vor allem erwähnt, um mal die Begrifflichkeiten klarzumachen,
was jetzt hier eigentlich was ist.
Stellarator ist halt das Bauprinzip.
Wendelstein ist die konkrete Installation, die hier betrieben wird.
Die Tokamak-Reaktoren werden an anderen Standorten gebaut, aber auch vom Max-Planck-Institut
gibt es, glaube ich, eine Tokamak-Installation.
Wir haben eine Tokamak-Versuchsanlage in Garching.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch ein großes System in ITER in Frankreich,
was ein sehr internationales Projekt ist.
Und man darf das auch nicht zu sehr auseinander dividieren. Also beides ist
magnetischer Einschluss, beides ist ringförmig, ist in dem Sinne wieder sehr ähnlich.
Es gibt, wenn man so mit einem Satz den Unterschied zwischen Stellarator und
Tokamak diesen beiden Sublinien im magnetischen Einschluss beschreiben will,
dann kann man sagen, im Tokamak muss ein starker Strom im Plasma fließen.
Im Stellarator kann man auf den verzichten.
Die Gründe haben wir schon erwähnt. Der starke Strom im Plasma des Tokamax erzeugt
die Verdrillung der Magnetfeldlinien.
Beim Stellarator wird die Verdrillung der Magnetfeldlinien durch die Formung der Spulen gemacht.
Genau. Kommen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz zu diesem Plasma selbst.
Klingt ja, ist ja so ein schönes Wort. Bei Plasma haben glaube ich alle immer
so Plasma-Lampen irgendwie vor Augen.
Aber ganz auf Augenblutplasma. Das höre ich oft.
Das ist mir jetzt nicht eingefallen. Okay, naja gut. Aber ja.
Was genau ist jetzt drin in der Röhre? Welchen Braten schiebt man jetzt sozusagen rein?
Woraus macht man das Plasma?
Wir haben ja schon über Gas gesprochen. Also wir reden von einem dünnen Gas.
So zur Orientierung unserer Anlage, die wir hier stehen haben.
Ich rede übrigens gar nicht so gerne vom Reaktor.
Können wir noch vertiefen.
Sondern von?
Die Anlage. Oder Maschine. Wir nennen sie auch gerne die Maschine.
Das klingt ein bisschen kräftiger.
Aber da reagiert schon Sachen zu.
Nee, da reagiert nichts.
Da reagiert nichts?
Zurzeit gar nichts. Also das heißt in dieser Anlage zur Orientierung,
wenn wir dort von dem Gas reden, ist das sowas wie 0,01 Gramm.
Also wirklich wenig Gas.
Von? Wasserstoff.
Wasserstoff. Was wir dort reinfüllen. Also alles fängt mit dem Gas an.
Man füllt also Wasserstoff, Gas, dieses niedrigdichte Gas ein.
Dieses Gas wird ionisiert, sprich es wird Energie eingekoppelt.
Und diese Energie ist hoch genug, dass die Atomverbünde auseinanderfallen.
Das ist gar nicht schwer, das
geht relativ schnell. Das passiert schon bei relativ geringen Energien.
Und wenn diese Atomverbünde zerfallen sind, dann besteht dieses Gas dann nicht
mehr aus neutralen Wasserstoffatomen oder Molekülen,
sondern nur noch aus den Wasserstoffkernen und freien Elektronen.
Und da reden wir von den Ionen und den Elektronen.
Und dieses Gemisch aus Ionen und Elektronen, die nicht mehr aneinander gebunden
sind, sondern sich frei bewegen können, diesen Materiezustand bezeichnet man als Plasma.
Das hört sich ganz skurril an, ist auch nicht unmittelbar ein Alltagsphänomen,
wenn wir jetzt hier auf der Straße spazieren gehen.
Kann es aber werden, wenn man nördlich genug ist und dort mal ein Nordlicht hat.
Ein Nordlicht ist ein Plasmazustand in der oberen Atmosphäre.
Die Auroren.
Die Aurora Borealis oder...
Die südliche Version davon. Man kann auch so kleine Plasmen haben in einer Gewitterstimmung.
Das St. Elmsfeuer, Segler kennen das. Das heißt einfach eine Lichterscheinung an der Massspitze.
Auch dort passiert so eine Inonisierung des atmosphärischen Gases.
Oder etwas spektakulärer, ein Blitz. Ein Blitz ist auch ein Plasma.
Oder eine Kerze.
Eine Kerze ist ein bisschen an der Grenze. Da sind wir Plasmaphysiker streng.
Das ist ein böser Grenzfall.
Ja, das leuchtet, das ist auch ein bisschen ionisiert, aber wir haben ja Kriterien
dafür, wann es ein Plasma ist und wann nicht.
Das ist ein übler Grenzfall.
Also das spielt nicht mehr nach den Spielregeln, nachdem sich ein Plasma verhält,
weil eine Kerze hat zu wenig Ionisation.
Der Ionisationsgrad ist sehr niedrig. Und damit beginnen die Effekte,
die für ein Plasma wichtig sind, marginal zu werden.
Alles ist von dem neutralen Gas und von der Chemie bestimmt.
Und damit ist das so ein bisschen außerhalb unseres Schirms.
Es gibt auch keine scharfe Grenze.
Also es gibt keinen Punkt, wo man sagt, jetzt ist es ein Plasma.
Sondern das ist ein weicher Übergang. Man darf sich das nicht wie so einen Phasenübergang
vorstellen, wie Schmelzen von Eis, sondern das kriecht so rein,
die Plasma-Eigenschaft in das Gas.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall so die Definition eines Plasmas,
dass wir eben in dem Sinne ein geladenes Gas haben und die Ladung wird aus den
Konstituenten, aus jedem Teilchen selbst bereitgestellt.
Aber die Gesamtladung ist de facto null, weil es ist immer gleich viel Plus wie Minus.
Genau, aber Wasserstoffatron besteht ja im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur aus einem
Proton und einem Elektron.
Und wenn sich das halt alles auflöst, dann wird einfach nur die Bindung zwischen
Elektron und dem Kern, also dem einen Proton aufgehoben.
Und man hat mehr oder weniger so eine Elektron-Proton-Suppe,
die insgesamt noch dieselbe Ladung hat wie vorher, aber sie ist ungleich verteilt.
Das Proton ist dann halt positiv. Und da spricht man dann eben von dem Ion,
wenn es sozusagen seines Elektrons beraubt ist.
Und das ist ja dann auch die Voraussetzung, dass das Magnetfeld drumherum da
überhaupt seine Wirkung entfallen kann.
Denke ich. Ja, erstens das. Also nur dadurch, dass man geladene Teilchen,
also dass man ein Gas ausgeladene Teilchen hat, reagiert das überhaupt auf die
magnetischen Feldlinien.
Und die eigentliche Fusion passiert ja bei den Kernen, also bei den Schweren,
bei den Ionen. Die Ionen fusionieren, die Elektronen machen ja nichts.
Die sind ja nur da. Die sorgen dann sozusagen für das Ladungsgleichgewicht.
Und wenn die zwei Protonen dann halt zusammenkommen, dann haben wir Helium.
Na, bei zwei Wasserstoffprotonen kriegen wir erstmal keine Helium.
Nee, warum nicht?
Nein,
also die Fusionsreaktion, von der wir reden, das sind zwei Isotope,
also zwei Varianten von Wasserstoff.
Also nicht der klassische Wasserstoff, den wir so kennen, der aus einem Proton besteht,
sondern die Fusion, die die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit hat, ist die Fusion von
schwerem Wasserstoff und superschwerem Wasserstoff.
Das ist im Falle von schweren Wasserstoff ein Proton und ein Neutron.
Und im Falle von super schweren Wasserstoff ein Proton und zwei Neutronen.
Also das Deuterium und das Tritium.
Die heißen auch Deuterium und Tritium. Das sind so die poetischen Namen, die man davon nimmt.
Aber Wasserstoffisotope, das heißt chemisch, sind die identisch zum Wasserstoff.
Die können auch Wasser bilden, schweres Wasser oder super schweres Wasser.
Reagieren chemisch genauso.
Aber sind eben schwerer, wie es der Name sagt. Nicht schwerer und super schwerer.
Und da ergibt eben halt die Kernphysik aus der Zusammensetzung dieses Kerns,
dass da die Fusion dramatisch viel wahrscheinlicher ist.
Mit ganz großer Mühe kann man auch reinen Wasserstoff, Protonen miteinander
fusionieren, das passiert im Inneren der Sonne.
Wir sprachen darüber, da brauchen wir äußerst extreme Bedingungen und man muss
auch wirklich richtig lange warten dafür.
Die Fusion von Deuterium und Tritium ist um 30 Größenordnungen wahrscheinlicher.
Und damit ist es dann das Naheliegende, damit mal anzufangen,
bevor man sich mit Fusion von Wasserstoff beschäftigt.
Aber wo kommen denn dann die Neutronen her?
Naja, das ist einfach die atomare Struktur. Also Deuterium ist einfach ein Element,
was auf der Erde auch verfügbar ist.
Das ist zu einem kleinen Prozentsatz einfach im Wasser enthalten.
Also Deuterium kann man so kaufen.
Mit tritium müsste das eigentlich auch der fall sein also ist
grundsätzlich auch so der fall hat aber einen
ärgerlichen nebeneffekt der tritium also tritium da ist der atomkern nicht mehr
stabil der zerfällt nach einer mittleren zeit von zwölf jahren 12,3 jahren das
heißt es gibt keine tritium vorräte weil das immer wieder alles zerfallen was
was was erzeugt wird es muss also immer wieder erzeugt werden,
Aber das sind eben halt die beiden Wasserstoffvarianten, die dann,
wenn sie verschmolzen werden, dann kommt tatsächlich dann das Helium raus.
Wenn man das mit dem eigentlichen Wasserstoff macht, wie im Inneren der Sonne,
dann braucht man einen mehrstufigen Prozess dafür.
Das ist der sogenannte Proton-Proton-Zyklus, da gibt es noch mehrere Zwischenschritte
und am Ende kommt trotzdem Helium raus.
Aber direkt aus zwei Protonen macht man kein Helium. Deshalb muss ich da intervenieren.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung. Das heißt, was wird jetzt sozusagen zum Plasma gebracht?
Das ist aber erstmal normaler Wasserstoff.
Richtig. Aus dem Betrieb von normalem Wasserstoff kann man einfach fast alles schon lernen.
Denn wir machen hier keine Fusionsforschung mit dem Fusionsprozess.
Der ist gut bekannt. Da gibt es nicht viel zu erforschen. Der ist tabelliert.
Kennt man alles. Da brauchen wir nichts rausfinden. Wir brauchen hier nicht
zum x-ten Mal Deutem und Tritium aufeinander zu schießen, um das zu fusionieren.
Also das ist alles schon gemacht, ist abgehakt.
Sondern das, was schwierig ist, ist der Plasmazustand. Also die Beherrschung
des Plasmazustandes und um auf das Gesagte zurückzukommen,
die Kunst der Wärmeisolation, also wie man das Magnetfeld so einrichtet,
dass man das Plasma überhaupt heiß bekommt in einer unserer kalten Umgebung.
Dieses dünne Gas, dass man das so heiß bekommt, das ist die Kunst.
Und das kann man super mit normalen Wasserstoff machen.
Da braucht man kein Deuterium, da braucht man kein Tritium dazu.
Ganz subtil, später gibt es dann schon wieder Unterschiede. Da reden wir dann vom Isotopeneffekt.
Aber ein Schritt nach dem anderen. Also wenn man die ganze Übung mit Wasserstoff
gemacht hat und wenn man das gut im Griff hat,
Das ist auch auf unserem Plan und dafür ist die Maschine auch gebaut.
Dann werden wir das Gleiche nochmal mit Deuterium machen, um zu sehen,
was sind denn tatsächlich die feinen Unterschiede. Aber es sind feine Unterschiede.
Der Teufel steckt immer im Detail, aber es ist der Schritt zwei.
Genau, wir sind ja noch mitten in der Entwicklung und es gibt sozusagen das Fernziel,
die Fusion tatsächlich durchzuführen, dann eben entsprechend aus der daraus
erzeugten Wärme dann andere Energieformen daraus zu erzeugen,
mit Turbinen oder was auch immer.
Aber wir befinden uns noch auf dem Weg dahin und derzeit befinden wir uns an
der Stelle, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
alles herauszufinden, was eben erstmal diesen definierten Zustand des Plasmas
erreichen und erhalten kann, um dann, wenn man sich sicher ist,
dass das funktioniert, den nächsten Schritt gehen zu können.
Genau, wir müssen erstmal,
den Materiezustand schaffen. Stabil.
Wir müssen es schaffen, den stabil herzustellen, unter dem Fusion effizient stattfindet.
Denn wie ich sagte, ein bisschen Fusion passiert immer, aber man muss den Materiezustand
so hinbekommen, dass möglichst viel Fusion passiert. Das ist das Ziel.
Etwas Fusion ist einfach, viel Fusion ist schwierig.
Für viel Fusion braucht man ganz genau definierte Parameter,
die zu diesem Materiezustand gehören. Also allem voran die Teilchendichte,
Teilchen pro Kubikmeter und die Temperatur.
Und dann die Kunst, das in einer kalten Umgebung unserer Welt herzustellen,
stabil, zuverlässig, kontrolliert.
Dann kommen wir noch mal auf das konkrete Design des Stellarator Maschine.
Ich habe mir das auch gerade mal angeschaut, sehr beeindruckende Technikinstallation.
Glaube ich, fast eine der größten Maschinen, die es vielleicht gibt, oder?
Das ist eine der zehn großen auf der Welt, ja.
Ein fetter Apparat mit 16 Metern Durchmesser hat man also diesen Ring und um
dieses Magnetfeld zu erzeugen,
in dem das Plasma dann vorgehalten werden soll oder auch wird schon,
ist also dieser große Torus, den man jetzt gebaut hat, umgeben von mehreren dieser Magnetspulen.
Die aber, um dann diese Verschlingung sozusagen zu erzeugen,
also diese Ungleichmäßigkeit zu erzeugen, auch selber ungleichmäßig geformt und angeordnet sind.
Ja, die ganze Kunst steckt in den Magneten drin. Denn die Ausführung der Magneten,
die Geometrie dieser Elektromagnete bestimmt die Geometrie des Magnetfeldes.
Und das musste man auch bitter lernen in der Physik, dass es auf die Geometrie
des Magnetfeldes wirklich ankommt.
Also in den Frühzeiten dieser Stellarator-Konfiguration, dieser Stellarator-Maschinen,
hat man das ein bisschen ad hoc gemacht.
Das heißt, man hat einfach ein ringförmiges, torusförmiges Magnetfeld.
Erzeugt so erstmal als basis genommen
und dann ja jetzt müssen wir diese verdrillung noch machen und
hat man einfach so eine helix reingepackt nicht oder eine doppel
helix und der helischen sachen hat man reingepackt das war einfach dafür gab
es keinen physikgrund sondern müssen es irgendwie verdrehen das war so im prinzip
diese der der ansatz schon ein bisschen intelligenter aber eigentlich ein bisschen
schuss ins blaue und das war eher eine enttäuschung also das heißt da war die
Wärmeisolation wirklich schlecht,
also viel schlechter als bei dem Tokamak-Prinzip, wo man sich immer so vergleichen durfte,
weil die sehr ähnlich sind, macht man natürlich den direkten Nachbarn zum Vergleich, guckt darüber.
Und beim Tokamak hat man einfach viel bessere Wärmeisolationen beobachtet und
damit viel höhere Temperaturen und hat sich also diesem Ziel,
dieser 100 Millionen Grad, dieser berühmten schon viel stärker angenähert und
damit war es erstmal eine Enttäuschung.
Und diese Enttäuschung saß tief, die saß so tief, dass viele Labors auf der
Welt gesagt haben, aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das Mist, wir haben es nicht
verstanden warum, aber wir lassen das mal.
Und haben sich einfach auf den Gewinner Pfad begeben und Tokamaks gebaut,
weil der einfach auch gut lief.
Und dann sagen, warum sollen wir jetzt unsere Arbeitskraft verbrennen an irgendetwas,
was nicht ordentlich läuft.
Eigentlich sind so zwei große Gruppen am Ball geblieben.
Es gab noch ein paar andere, die auch mitbetrieben haben, aber zwei große Gruppen.
Das ist ein großes Institut in Japan und halt unser Institut.
Und bei uns wurde so ein bisschen grüblerisch sich auch die Frage gestellt,
woran liegt das eigentlich?
Und da ist eine ganze Forschergeneration reingegangen in dieses drüber brüten
und dieses Nachschöpfen, was eigentlich die Gründe für diese Enttäuschung sind.
Also warum ist der Stellerator schlecht? Das war die entscheidende Frage.
Und das ist so Schritt für Schritt gelungen, das so zu verstehen,
also was wirklich mit diesen individuellen Teilchen passiert,
also warum die entkommen können.
Denn jeder Wärmeverlust ist am Ende ein Entkommen.
Das Transport, wir nennen das dann ja Physiktransport.
Woher kommen diese Transportprozesse?
Wenn man es dann verstanden hat, dann ist der nächste Schritt,
dass man sich überlegen kann, wie kann man das heilen.
Und dann ist so Schritt für Schritt sind diese ganzen Nachteile,
die der Stellarator einfach bei dieser Ad-Hoc-Magnetfeldkonfiguration hat,
sind geheilt worden, indem man das Magnetfeld in seiner Form angepasst hat.
Das heißt also, die Krümmung der Magnetfeldlinien, auch wie dicht die liegen,
also die Stärke des Magnetfeldes, wie die Stärke variieren muss,
Das hat man dann immer mithilfe von numerischen Codes immer weiter so justiert,
dass es zu dem Plasma passte,
dass also dieser Transport verringert wurde.
Und wenn man dann die Geometrie hat, dann rechnet man rückwärts die Spulen aus.
Also das heißt, die Spulen, die sehen ein bisschen merkwürdig aus,
wenn man die jetzt so anguckt, so im Bild anschaut, aber die sind genau so,
wie die Physik sie haben will.
Sie sehen so ein bisschen aus wie so verbogene Karabinerhaken.
Ja, ich würde manchmal gefragt, ob die vom Laster gefallen sind oder ob da noch
jemand dann dreimal rübergefahren ist, aber nein, das ist die natürlichste Form,
also wirklich eine evolutionäre Form.
Ja, also eine Form, die, wenn man sie halt jetzt um diesen Torus herum arrangiert,
diese Verdrehung des Magnetfelds im Prinzip so nachbildet, also man hat es quasi
mathematisch vom Ziel her in die Form zurückgerechnet, wenn ich es richtig verstehe.
Und diese Magnetfelder müssen aber auch extrem stark sein, damit sie halt bis
in die Mitte reinwirken.
Nein, das geht gar nicht um das bis in die Mitte reinwirken.
Also in der Tat ist das Magnetfeld auf der Spule stärker als im Zentrum.
Also das heißt, da hat man schon auch eine Variation von dem Ausgangspunkt des
Magnetfeldes zu dem Ort, wo das Plasma dann auch so sitzt oder den größeren
Teil des Volumens, wo es sitzt.
Aber man muss das Magnetfeld insgesamt einfach stark genug machen,
dass die geladenen Teilchen wirklich effizient an die Magnetfeldlinien gebunden sind.
Denn das Magnetfeld wäre das geringer, wäre diese Bindung an die Magnetfeldlinien
schwächer, so kann man sich das vorstellen.
Und auch das geht wieder auf Kosten der Wärmeisolation.
Also die Wärmeisolation wird besser und wird systematisch besser mit höherem Magnetfeld.
Also müssen die Magnetfelder stark sein?
Also müssen sie stark sein, weil es geht alles um die möglichst hohe Wärmeisolation,
die alleine dem Zweck dient, dass man die Temperaturen erreichen kann,
die man braucht, damit Fusion effizient stattfindet.
Aber wenn man jetzt ein starkes Magnetfeld braucht, muss man wiederum sehr viel
Energie in diese Spulen reinschicken, die ja dann wahrscheinlich auch wiederum ziemlich warm werden.
Ja, und das ist ganz blöd. Also da kommt man recht...
Relativ schnell zum Schluss, dass man mehr Energie für die Spulen braucht,
als man jemals rausbekommen würde. Und da ist es wieder nichts,
was man gebrauchen kann.
Weshalb der vernünftige Weg ist, und das ist eigentlich banal dieser Weg,
ist, dass man den wohlbekannten Effekt der Superleitung nimmt.
Superleitung ist ja nun auch schon ein uraltes Phänomen der Physik.
Also schon ein bisschen her, dass wir es 100 Jahre gefeiert haben.
Es gibt eben Materialien, Legierungen vor allem, metallische Legierungen,
aber inzwischen auch keramische Materialien, die unter kalten Bedingungen supraleitend werden.
Das heißt also einen elektrischen Strom völlig ohne Widerstand leiten.
Und eine supraleitende Spule, also ein Elektromagnet, ein supraleitender Elektromagnet,
funktioniert am Ende so, dass man den Strom dort hineinschickt und der fließt
ohne elektrischen Widerstand.
Das heißt, er fließt, bis man ihn wieder rausnimmt.
Damit ist dieser Magnet am Ende nicht unterscheidbar von einem Permanentmagneten.
Er sitzt dort und erzeugt einfach das Magnetfeld und erzeugt weder Wärme noch
Braucherenergie, weil der Strom ohne elektrischen Widerstand fließt.
Und ein Magnet braucht ja nur dann Energie, wenn der elektrische Strom in Wärme
umgewandelt wird, die auch lästig ist, die man abführen muss,
die man auch gar nicht haben wollte.
Also insofern der Weg zu gehen ist Supraleitung. Und unsere Magnete,
also unsere 70 Magnete, sind alle Supraleiten.
Das superleitende Material ist ein alter Klassiker, einer der ältesten Supraleiter,
die so der technischen Verwendung sind, Niob-Titan.
Und Niob-Titan ist bei minus 270 Grad Celsius, also bei 3 Kelvin,
sehr zuverlässig Supraleitend.
Das ist ja dann ganz einfach. Da muss man ja nur auf drei Kelvin runterkühlen,
während man ein paar Meter entfernt davon ein Plasma extrem heiß haben möchte.
Das ist nicht das Problem. Denn die Spulen sehen das Plasma ja gar nicht.
Die wissen gar nicht, dass da ein Plasma ist. Das ist den Spulen auch völlig egal.
Das ist erstens ganz wenig Materie, zweitens ist die ewig weit weg.
Die ist ja auch sogar richtig physisch abgetrennt durch das Vakuumgefäß.
Das Plasma wohnt ja in einem Stahlgefäß, was zunächst evakuiert wird,
sonst könnte man ja gar nicht so ein dünnes Gas dort drin einleiten und betreiben.
Also die anderen Gase müssen sozusagen weg sein.
Also man erzeugt erstmal ein Ultrahochvakuum, also quasi ein Nix.
Und dort leitet man dieses hunderttausendfach verdünnte Wasserstoffgas ein.
Und dieses Gefäß, also die Magnete befinden sich außerhalb dieses Gefäßes.
Das heißt also aus der Magnetperspektive, wenn ich jetzt so ein Magnet wäre,
keine Ahnung, was in mir da passiert, ist mir auch egal. Ich erzeuge mein Magnetfeld.
Also das heißt, den Magneten ist das Plasma völlig egal.
Allemal in erster und zweiter Ordnung.
Trotzdem muss man ja irgendwie noch mal die Wärme auch in dieses Plasma hineinbekommen,
weil sonst wird es ja nicht heiß.
Also komplett entkoppelt voneinander. Das hat nichts mit den Magneten zu tun.
Also die Magnete müssen auf minus 270 Grad runtergekühlt werden und es ist trotzdem
nicht einfach, aber es hat nichts mit dem Plasma zu tun, sondern es hat damit zu tun,
dass unsere Welt, unsere Umgebung nicht bei minus 270 Grad ist,
sondern dass wir unsere Raumtemperatur 20, 30 Grad haben, so rundherum.
Das heißt also, wir müssen von unserer Raumtemperatur auf diese minus 270 Grad
runterkommen und wir müssen dann eben sehr scharf unterscheiden zwischen der
warmen Welt, das ist einfach unsere Welt, nicht die Welt des Plasmas,
sondern die menschliche Welt, das ist die warme Welt und die kalte Welt,
das ist die Welt der Spulen.
Deswegen befinden sich diese Spulen wiederum in einem Vakuum,
was wir zwischen dem Plasmagefäß und dem Außengefäß aufbauen.
Damit sind die wiederum wärmeisoliert. Wenn man in einem Vakuum drin sitzt,
da hat man keine Wärmeverbindung zu unserer warmen Welt, zu unserer menschlichen warmen Welt.
Das heißt, das muss man auch erstmal wieder entkoppeln, also nochmal in Isolationsaufgabe, aber anders.
Und zweitens müssen die Magnete natürlich aktiv gekühlt werden.
Denn zunächst beginnen die mit Raumtemperatur.
Also wenn die so einfach da stehen, jetzt, wo sie das Ding besucht haben,
haben die Raumtemperatur.
Und dann dafür benutzt man einen Kühlschrank. Was also nicht anders ist als
das raumwarme Bier, was man eben halt gerne etwas kälter haben würde.
Dafür benutzt man auch einen Kühlschrank. Nur ist unser Kühlschrank ein bisschen größer.
Das Kühlmittel ist flüssiges Helium.
Also Heliumgas, was dann eben in den flüssigen Zustand gebracht wird.
Und flüssiges Helium ist so in diesem Bereich von minus 72 Grad,
3 Kelvin, da kann man das ganz gut so betreiben.
Und wir beginnen also mit Heliumgas und nach dem alten Kühlschrankprinzip,
das heißt also diesem Expansions- und Verdichtungsprinzip, wie im Kühlschrank
halt so funktioniert, wird dieses Heliumgas dann immer weiter runtergekühlt, bis es flüssig wird.
Und dieses flüssige Helium zirkuliert dann in den Spulen und kühlt die Spulen
auf die niedrige Temperatur, auf diese Minus 270 Grad ab, die erforderlich sind,
damit die Spulen superleitend sind. Sonst ist Niob Titan nicht superleitend.
Das ist im ganzen Gegenteil, ein ganz schrecklich schlechter Leiter.
Wie lange dauert das, bis man das so kalt kriegt bei diesem Riesenapparat?
Ich meine, es ist ja eine ganze Menge Zeug.
Wenn alles gut geht, vier bis sechs Wochen.
Vier bis sechs Wochen.
Na gut, das sind 430 Tonnen,
Material, die runtergekühlt werden müssen von Raumtemperatur auf minus 270 Grad, das dauert halt.
Ja okay, nur dass man sich das mal vorstellt, das ist jetzt nicht so eine Maschine,
die man so einschaltet wie einen Kühlschrank, nach einer halben Stunde passt das schon irgendwie,
sondern bei dieser Dimension und dieser Menge an Material, die hier zum Einsatz
kommt, ist das ein Prozess, den man mal nicht eben mal für den Tag einschaltet,
sondern das ist eher so eine Phase.
Also wenn man hier beschließt, wir wollen das Ding jetzt mal wirklich auch wieder
in Betrieb nehmen und real Experimente durchführen und den ganzen Prozess überwachen,
ist das so ein längerer Zeitraum, um das überhaupt erstmal zu erreichen.
Allein schon nur, um diese Spulen runter zu kühlen, ist vielleicht noch nicht mal das Einzige.
Das ist nicht das Einzige. Insgesamt brauchen wir sowas wie fünf Monate,
um die Maschine betriebsbereit zu machen, wenn man alles zusammenrechnet.
Aber das Abkühlen ist ein großer Prozess, weil der ist einfach auch gegeben
durch die schiere Masse.
Die schiere Masse, die runter zu kühlen ist und die Kühlkapazität unseres Kühlschranks.
Der Kühlschrank hat auch schon eine satte elektrische Anschlussleistung von
so etwa zwei Megawatt, die dann eben halt auch Tag und Nacht verbraucht werden.
Also die Stromrechnung ist auch nicht ganz ohne.
Ja, also derzeit macht man hier noch keinen Energiegewinn. Gehen wir vielleicht
auch mal diesen Prozess durch, weil ich finde das glaube ich ganz interessant.
Daran kann man ja dann auch sehen, was letzten Endes jetzt wirklich passiert.
Also sagen wir mal jetzt, morgen geht es los,
alle Vorbereitungen sind abgeschlossen, alle Warnsignale sind ausgeschaltet,
jetzt schaltet man erstmal sozusagen den Kühlschrank ein und sorgt dafür,
also wahrscheinlich wird erstmal das Vakuum hergestellt, also sowohl innerhalb des Vakuumes,
Ich weiß nicht, wie nennt man den Bereich? Plasma-Rohrs? Kann man das so nennen? Wie heißt das?
Wir reden von Plasmagefäß.
Plasmagefäß, okay. Also erstmal das Vakuum für das Plasmagefäß,
das Vakuum für die es umgebenden Spulen und der Kühlschrank sorgt dafür,
dass die Spulen runtergekühlt werden und das läuft dann eben über mehrere Wochen.
Was für andere Prozesse müssen noch gestartet werden, um letzten Endes eine
Betriebsbereitschaft herzustellen.
Ach, Sie haben es ja schon die Wesentlichen so genannt. Also es beginnt eben
erstmal mit dem Evakuieren, also mit dem Herstellen von Vakuum,
von Plasmagefäß und dem Ausstieggefäß.
Das dauert wahrscheinlich auch eine Weile, ne?
Ja, so ein paar Tage dauert das auch, paar Tage pumpt man da schon,
wenn man keine Lacks hat.
Ja.
Also passiert, dass irgendwas schief geht, dass man, wir haben sehr viele Öffnungen,
wir haben 500 Öffnungen, da kann das schon in dem einen wie dem anderen Gefäß
schon mal passieren, dass man einen Vakuum-Lack hat und was man erstmal suchen
muss. und so eine Lecksuche kann auch schon durchaus dauern.
Aber wenn alles gut geht, dann ist man in so einer Woche etwa durch.
Und wenn diese Vakuumbedingungen hergestellt sind, dann kann man mit dem Abkühlen
beginnen. Wir sprachen über das Abkühlen.
Also das Abkühlen von Raumtemperatur auf minus 270 Grad von dem ganzen Magnetsystem
und auch den ganzen Stützstrukturen.
Die Magnete sind ja an Stahlstützstrukturen festgeschraubt.
Das ist eine massive Stahlkonstruktion.
Alles das muss runtergekühlt werden.
Wenn das passiert ist, müssen wir noch das Vakuum im Plasmagefäß verbessern.
Das reicht uns denn noch nicht, denn das stand jetzt ja diese Tage einfach so an der Luft.
Also Luftfeuchtigkeit und Menschen haben drin gearbeitet.
Also das heißt, es muss Schmutz raus, also auch Sauerstoff muss raus,
Wasser, was in der Wand ist.
Das heißt, wir heizen dieses Plasmagefäß aus auf 150 Grad.
Das wird mithilfe von heißem Wasser auf Kühlrohren, die auf das Gefäß raufgeschweißt
sind, wird das gesamte Gefäß auf 150 Grad ausgeheizt.
Und damit treiben wir das Wasser aus der Wand raus und pumpen es mit unseren Turbopumpen ab.
Wird sozusagen ausgebrannt.
Ja, es wird einfach gebacken. Also dieses Plasma-Gefäß wird einmal moderat gebacken.
Und wenn das abgeschlossen ist, dann ist das Vakuum gut.
Und dann, beziehungsweise auch schon parallel dazu, werden zahllose Tests durchgeführt.
Und die Magnete werden alle nochmal einzeln durchgetestet, ob sie sich in einem
elektrotechnisch guten Zustand befinden.
Denn man schaltet das nicht einfach ein wie eine Nachttischlampe.
Dafür sind die einfach doch zu wertvoll und nicht zu empfindlich.
Aber da darf nichts schief gehen.
Also Reparaturen an den Magneten, das ist etwas, was man nicht gerne haben möchte.
Auch wegen der Zugänglichkeit und wegen der Folgen. Das dauert immer alles ewig.
Also das heißt, man muss sich sicher sein, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Also ganze große Testsequenzen müssen durchgeführt werden, auch für den gesamten Steuersystem.
Am Ende summiert sich das ganz schön auf und dann kommen da eben halt diese fünf Monate daraus.
Und...
Und wenn dann dieser Zustand hergestellt ist, also Vakuum ist perfekt,
man nimmt keine Lecks wahr, man hat die entsprechende Temperatur der Spulen, was passiert dann?
Was ist das nächste, was man dann, dann kann man ja im Prinzip anfangen,
ein Gas einzuführen, leiten,
das dünne Gas, das Wasserstoff, zu ionisieren und dann schaltet man die Magnete
an und wodurch wird das Gas dann heiß?
Ja, erstmal ist die Sequenz andersrum, also man schaltet erstmal den Magnet an.
Okay, und dann das Gas, okay.
Weil die Magnete einfach auch so superleitende Magnete so angenehm sind.
Wie gesagt, das ist wie so ein Permanentmagnet. Die werden einfach morgens hochgefahren.
Da wird der Strom dort...
Quasi eingeleitet in diese Magnete. Das ist so zwischen 10.000 und 15.000 Ampere.
Das ist schon ordentlich Strom.
Und dann steht das Magnetfeld. Und dann leitet man Gas ein über ein Ventil.
Und gleichzeitig laufen wir die Pumpen. Die Turbopumpen und die Vorpumpen.
Das erzeugt dann erstmal so ein Gleichgewicht.
Also die Vakuumpumpen?
Ja, die Vakuumpumpen. Die pumpen die ganze Zeit. Es ist nicht so,
dass man die nach ausschaltet und man tut Gas rein, das wird auch manchmal so
vermutet, sondern es ist einfach ein fester Zyklus.
Das heißt, man hat eingeleitetes Gas und es wird permanent gepumpt und als Folge
ergibt es dann einen Gasdruck aus diesem Gleichgewicht aus Einleitung und Abpumpen.
Und dieses eingeleitete Gas, das wird dann in den Plasmazustand versetzt,
also wird dann ionisiert und da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Diese Möglichkeiten, die heißen alle Plasmaheizung, das sind Plasmaheizmethoden.
Heizung heißen die, weil einfach Energie von außen in dieses Gas eingebracht
wird. Das Gas wird also in dem Sinne aufgeheizt, es wird Energie reingebracht.
Eines unserer wichtigsten Verfahren basiert auf Mikrowellen es werden also Mikrowellen
erzeugt im Prinzip wie die Küchenmikrowelle mit Mikrowellenröhren sehr große Mikrowellenröhren,
Diese Mikrowellen, die heizen erstmal Elektronen,
das heißt so ein klein bisschen ist dieses Gas immer ionisiert,
das heißt ein paar Elektronen findet man immer, die sitzen in diesem Magnetfeld,
durch ihre Wechselwirkung mit dem Magnetfeld machen die Elektronen eine Spiralbewegung
um die Magnetfelderlinien herum.
An diese Spiralbewegung koppeln diese Mikrowellen direkt an.
Die haben selber ebenfalls eine Rotation eingeprägt und die koppeln direkt daran
an, machen denn diese Elektronen sehr heiß, sodass die Elektronen wiederum Stöße
machen mit neutralen Gasatomen und dann passiert so ein Lawineneffekt.
Und dieser Lewin-Effekt führt dazu, dass innerhalb von winzigen Bruchteilen
von Sekunden das ganze Plasma aufgebaut wird und dann ist das gesamte Gas ionisiert.
Dann hat man also keine neutralen Wasserstoffatome mehr im Zentrum des Plasmas,
sondern nur noch Protonen und Elektronen.
Und ist das jetzt schon die Zieltemperatur, die man haben will,
die ist dann sofort erreicht oder muss man da noch mit drauf haben?
Unter guten Bedingungen, also wenn man die günstigen Bedingungen hat,
ist sie dann innerhalb von Millisekunden erreicht.
Okay, also es ist mehr ein Einschalten.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Einschalten.
Das ist nicht nochmal vier Wochen warten. Das geht ganz schnell. Okay, gut.
Und dann glüht das Plasma und befindet sich jetzt quasi immer wieder bei einer Wurst.
Jetzt haben wir sozusagen die Plasmawurst in unserem Gefäß von dem Magnetfeld eingeschlossen.
Und da existiert das dann erstmal so vor sich hin.
Ja, dann sitzt das da.
Okay und das ist jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, erstmal das eigentliche Ziel derzeit
im Forschungsfortschritt,
das kontrolliert zu erreichen, aber das muss jetzt auch eine gewisse Qualität haben.
Also es reicht jetzt nicht einfach nur irgendwie Plasma, sondern es gibt ja
wahrscheinlich dann Qualitätskriterien,
die dieses Plasma erfüllen muss, damit es dann für einen später eingeleiteten
Fusionsprozess die idealen Bedingungen bereitstellt.
Wie beobachtet man jetzt dieses System weil,
also mit dem was wir bisher besprochen haben ist das ja alles eine Blackbox
aber abgesehen davon dass man jetzt Mikrowellenstrahlung dort,
einbringt man muss es ja auch in irgendeiner Form messen und mal wissen was
passiert jetzt eigentlich auch genau das was wir wollen wie beobachtet man das.
Ja, in der Tat brauchen wir jetzt ja die Kenngrößen. Und über einige Kenngrößen
haben wir ja schon gesprochen.
Die Teilchendichte, Anzahl der Teilchen pro Kubikmeter. Also das heißt,
man muss eine Dichtemessung machen.
Der zweite wichtige Parameter ist die Temperatur. Wie heiß ist das?
Also welche Temperatur äquivalent hat die Bewegung der Ionen und die Bewegung der Elektronen?
Beobachtung an beides, weil die auch miteinander verkoppelt sind.
Ich hatte ja schon erwähnt, dass wir die Elektronen heizen. die elektronen
ionisieren aber die elektronen geben auch wiederum energie
an die ionen weiter das ist alles miteinander verschränkt also
das steht im wärmekontakt miteinander das heißt wir heizen über die elektronen
die ionen wir haben auch andere heizmethoden wo die ionen direkt heizen und
dann kombinieren wir die auch zusammen so oder so man braucht also auf diese
beiden kenngrößen braucht man und man braucht die auch mit räumlicher auflösung
denn die sind nicht etwa konstant.
Sondern die ändern sich etwa, wenn man vom Zentrum raus geht.
Im Zentrum ist es am heißesten und eben halt auch am dichtesten.
Und dann fällt das zum Rand sowohl die Temperatur als auch die Teilchenzahl
ab. Wir nennen das denn Profile. Das sind Profildaten.
Also wie so ein Reifenprofil.
Kann man sich das vorstellen. Das ist eine Größe, die auch räumlich variiert.
Vor allem eben halt in der Richtung senkrecht zum Magnetfeld.
Also von innen nach außen. Das sind die Profildaten.
Da gibt es auch gewisse Variationen, die entlang des Torus sind,
die sind auch wichtig, aber das ist schon die höhere Kunst.
So oder so braucht man also räumliche Auflösung erstmal von diesen grundsätzlichen Kennedaten.
Ein weiterer Punkt, den man zur Beurteilung der Güte des Plasmas braucht,
ist die Güte des Wärmeeinschlusses.
Und dahinter steht folgende Logik. Man kann ein Plasma ja sehr heiß machen,
indem man es einfach sehr stark heizt.
Also mit endlos viel Energie heizt.
Also es ist einfach das mit Geld heiß machen. Man kauft einfach so viel Heizleistung,
wie die Kasse hergibt und dann kriegt man schon irgendwann ein heißes Plasma.
Das sagt aber nichts aus über die Güte der Wärmeisolation, auf der ich mal so
rumreite, also wie gut das Magnetfeld ist, wie gut der Einschluss ist.
Sondern die Kunst ist ja mit möglichst wenig Heizleistung eine hohe Plasmatemperatur zu erzeugen.
Und das ist die dritte große Kerngröße, das ist die sogenannte Energieeinschlusszeit.
Und das hört sich so ein bisschen seltsam an, warum man das in Zeit misst,
aber das ist eigentlich sehr anschaulich.
Man kann Wärmeisolation sehr
gut als Zeit charakterisieren. Und das kennt man sogar aus dem Alltag.
Wenn man in seinem Haus ist und die Heizung abschaltet.
Wie lange bleibt es warm?
Wie lange bleibt es warm? Und das ist bestimmt durch die Güte der Wärmeisolation.
Wenn Sie nur Einfachverglasung haben und dünne Wände, dann kühlt das viel schneller ab.
Das heißt also, eine lange Abkühlzeit ist ein Zeichen für eine gute Wärmeisolation.
Das gleiche gilt für die Plasmaphysik.
Diese Einschlusszeit soll so groß wie möglich sein.
Und da gibt es so gut wie möglich, also am besten unendlich lang,
dass wir die perfekte Wärmeisolation ist, die Wärme bleibt immer drin.
Das wäre so ein Extremfall. Aber da gibt es eben halt so Kennzahlen,
Erfahrungswerte, die man eben halt aus allen Maschinen der ganzen Welt zusammengesammelt
hat über die Jahrzehnte, sodass man so eine Orientierung hat,
was so der typische Korridor da ist, den man so erreichen kann und an dem reiben
sich alle. Aber im Prinzip gilt das Ziel so gut wie möglich.
Aber das, was so eben mit den technologisch realisierbaren Magneten heutzutage
und der Optimierung der Magnetfeldgeometrie möglich ist, das ist dann so die
Zielzahl, die man dort erreichen muss.
Da muss man so gut wie möglich, aber eben mehr ist dann auch nicht drin,
erreichen. also die Güte der Wärmeisolation, dann gibt es eben halt einen Korridor
für die Teilchendichte und es gibt einen Korridor für die Temperatur.
Und diese drei Größen muss man so zusammenbringen und das ist auch in ein konkretes
Kriterium hineingegossen, das sogenannte Lawson-Kriterium, wo man eine Grenze
überschreiten muss und dann wird Fusion effizient.
Dann wird die so effizient, dass man mehr Fusionsenergie, das ist dann so die
heilige Kurve, wo mehr Fusionsenergie rauskommt, als man reinsteckt,
da gibt es noch eine zweite heilige Kurve, da ist.
Die Energie, die im Plasma durch Fusion entsteht, hoch genug,
um das Plasma selber zu heizen.
Dann braucht man keine externe Heizung mehr und dann brennt es einfach vor sich
hin. Das ist dann das brennende Plasma.
Und diese beiden Punkte, die haben auch einen schönen Fachbegriff.
Das eine ist der Break-Even-Punkt, also der Durchbruchpunkt.
Genauso viel Energie wie rein wie raus.
Und das andere ist eben das Burning-Plasma, das brennende Plasma.
Und das kann man sich dann vorstellen wie so eine Gasflamme.
Wie eine chemische Flamme. brennt einfach. Muss man nichts mehr machen von außen.
Braucht kein Streichholz mehr. Brennt. Kerze brennt.
Und im Idealfall bedeutet das dann später, dass man eine fortlaufende,
Fusionstätigkeit angestoßen hat und dann kommt man einfach Wärme raus.
Da hat man einen Gasofen.
Genau. Weil durch diese Fusionsprozesse letzten Endes Elektronen freigesetzt werden, die,
quasi in der Außenwand aufgefangen werden und dann als Wärme abgenommen werden kann.
Nee, Elektronen werden da gar nicht aufgefangen.
Neutronen meinte ich.
Neutronen, ja. Ja,
aber die Neutronen, die entkommen ja gleich dem Volumen und gehen in die Wand
und erzeugen ja diese Wärmeauskopplung.
Das heißt, damit zapft man quasi dann dieses Plasma an, den Fusionsprozess an
nach außen und erzeugt damit einfach Wärme.
Das Aufrechterhalten der Plasmatemperatur passiert durch das andere Fusionsprodukt,
nämlich durch die Heliumkerne.
Die verbleiben ja da drin. Diese werden ja auch wieder vom Magnetfeld festgehalten
und haben aber auch Energie, haben einen Anteil Energie und diese Energie geben
sie an das Plasma wieder weiter.
Dadurch bleibt es heiß.
Es heizt sich selber.
Aber es heizt eben auch drumherum, sodass man eben dann auch den eigentlichen Effekt hat.
Das ist erstmal die Selbstheizung und das Drumherum geschieht durch die Neutronen,
durch die Auskopplung von den Neutronen. Das sind so zwei Zweige, die sich auftrennen.
Die Heliumkerne sind für die Heizung des Plasmas zuständig und die Neutronen
sind für die Heizung der Wand zuständig, was denn die für uns nutzbare Wärme ist.
Genau. Aber jetzt weiß ich immer noch nicht so richtig, wie schaut man rein?
Also wir haben diese ganzen Kennzahlen, die wir erreichen wollen.
Das ist ja, sagen wir mal, jetzt auch gerade der Fokus, wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe, dass man also das jetzt optimieren will, also dem aktuellen
Stand der Forschung hier.
Wie beobachtet man diese Kennzahlen? Wie misst man die?
Da gibt es einen ganzen Strauß an Methoden.
Die ausprobiert werden oder die erforderlich sind?
Also benutzt man jetzt nur so viele Methoden wie möglich, um zu gucken,
was es am Ende braucht oder ist es jetzt schon klar, dass man sehr viele verschiedene braucht?
Sowohl als auch. Einerseits ist die Methodik der Plasmabeobachtung durchaus
ein Forschungsgebiet, was sich ständig in Entwicklung befindet,
wo man die Genauigkeit, aber auch die Auflösung sowohl im Raum wie auch in Zeit
immer wieder erhöht, die Aussagekraft erhöht.
Und weil es auch durchaus schwierige Techniken sind und schwierige Methoden
sind, physikalische Methoden sind, braucht man wiederum Redundanz.
Also das heißt, man beobachtet die eine Größe nicht nur mit einer Methode,
sondern auch gerne mal mit zwei oder mit drei verschiedenen Methoden,
um sicherzustellen, dass die übereinander liegen, dass die die gleiche Aussage machen.
Also nur dann kann man im strengen experimentalfysikalischen Sinne seinen Daten
auch wirklich trauen, wenn man mit völlig unterschiedlichen Methoden,
mit völlig unterschiedlichen Blickwinkeln zum gleichen Ergebnis kommt.
So streng ist ja Wissenschaft. Ähm,
multipliziert schon die Anzahl der Instrumente. Also dass man da einen mehrfachen
Blick auf die gleiche Größe nimmt.
Dann werden diese Methoden alle weiterentwickelt. Und da gibt es eben passive
Methoden, die einfach das Licht angucken, aus dem Licht selber Schlüsse ziehen.
Dann gibt es aktive Methoden, die mit starken Lasern arbeiten.
Dann etwa Streuung oder Interferometrie machen. Das heißt also Veränderung der
Wellenlänge des Laserlichtes.
Also wie gesagt, ein ganz breites Methodenspektrum, was man denn dort abdeckt.
Einige Methoden funktionieren nur am Rand, andere Methoden funktionieren nur
im Zentrum, andere Methoden funktionieren im Übergangsbereich.
Es gibt auch nicht one size fits all, nicht sozusagen die magische Plasma-Beobachtungsmethode,
die einem einfach alles liefert, was man wissen möchte, die gibt es nicht.
Sondern man muss da wirklich einen Indizienprozess führen, also ganz viele Puzzlesteine
zusammenfügen, die auch manchmal nicht so richtig zusammenpassen wollen,
weil es alles mit so ein bisschen schwammig, auch mit Unsicherheiten so versehen ist.
Und dann braucht man den Puzzlestein eben auch gleich mehrfach,
damit man da so sagen kann, okay, ist das jetzt wirklich der Richtige?
Und aus daraus ergibt sich so ein Gesamtbild.
Und dieses Gesamtbild, also dieses ganze Spektrum, was sich da aus dem Gesamtbild
ergibt, also das Methodenspektrum, das bezeichnen wir als Plasma-Diagnostik.
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Eigenbegriff, der sich hier bei uns so etabliert hat.
Und er dann immer so ein bisschen wie an so einem patienten
der diagnostiziert wird mit ganz vielen
instrumenten von allen seiten wo versucht wird
herauszufinden wie es diesen patienten dann so geht also das heißt die vielfachheit
der methode und die jeweilige spezialisierung der methode auf bestimmte bereiche
oder bestimmte fragestellungen ist ganz ganz essentiell um ein gesamtbild dafür
zu geben und die sache wird dann besonders.
Ja, besonders delikat, wenn man dann noch den Zeitaspekt reinbringt.
Denn das musste man auch erstmal lernen, dass dieses Gas gar nicht mal so friedlich
ist, also einfach nicht so als Gas dort fröhlich sitzt und nichts macht,
sondern dass es ein hochdynamischer Prozess ist.
Dadurch, dass es ein geladenes Gas ist, was einem Magnetfeld ausgesetzt ist,
ist dieses geladene Gas auch in der Lage, elektrische Felder zu bilden.
Also kleine Abweichungen zwischen der Dichte der Elektronen und der Ionen erzeugt
sofort starke elektrische Felder.
Und die in Kombination mit den magnetischen Feldern, und diese elektrischen
Felder können sich nur für kurze Zeit bilden, erzeugt etwas,
was wir als Dynamiken bezeichnen.
Das heißt, es wird ein dynamisches System, es beginnt sich räumlich und zeitlich zu entwickeln.
Und zwar auf Skalen, die können von Millimeter reichen bis Meter reichen,
also alles mögliche passiert da.
Und die Königsdisziplin da drin ist dann die Plasmaturbulenz,
auch das musste man mühsam lernen, dass dieses Plasma sogar sich wie ein turbulentes
Medium entwickelt, wie wir es etwa vom Wetter her kennen.
Also wenn wir draußen einen schönen Nordoststurm haben und hier Bäume und,
Menschen durchgeschüttelt werden, dann merkt man diese Turbulenz dieses Gases
und ein Plasma ist am Ende genauso ein turbulentes Gas.
Das kann Wirbel bilden, das kann starke Strömungen bilden, die mal von links,
mal von rechts kommen, die manchmal aufweilen, dann wieder verschwinden,
die also eine starke zeitliche Entwicklung haben, die aber auch eine räumliche
Komponente hat, eine stark ausgeprägte räumliche Komponente.
Und auch das muss man alles durch seine Instrumente abdecken.
Nämlich erst mit diesem dynamischen Bild, also das Plasma als dynamisches Phänomen,
hat man tatsächlich die ganze Geschichte.
Und da kommt dann auch wieder die Kunst rein, die zu verfolgen ist,
nämlich dieses Plasma tatsächlich und die Dynamiken dieses Plasmas unter Kontrolle
zu haben, so dass man einen kontrollierten Zustand herstellt,
also einen möglichst ruhigen Zustand herstellt.
Sprech, das System muss adaptiv funktionieren, all diese Messungen in Echtzeit
das Plasma beobachten und daraus wiederum Schlüsse zu ziehen,
wie man hier nachregelt.
Was lässt sich derzeit nachregeln? Was kann man beeinflussen,
wenn man jetzt sieht, hier haben wir Turbulenzen,
hier kippen mir die Magnetfelder ein bisschen zu sehr ab, ist die Temperatur
nicht stabil, was auch immer gemessen wird.
Was kann man in dem Moment denn
tun, um dieses Plasma wieder sozusagen in Reihe und Glied zu bekommen?
Da gibt es an sich drei Schritte oder drei Ebenen. Das eine ist einfach Vermeidung.
Also das hat ja allerlei Möglichkeiten, ein solches Plasma zu erzeugen unter
verschiedenen Betriebsparametern.
Dann hat man etwa den Gasdruck, mit dem man das Gas reinfüllt,
die Heizleistung, wo man die Heizleistung genau hinbringt und und und.
Also das heißt, im Prinzip macht man ja am Anfang so eine Art Setup,
mit dem man ein Plasma erzeugt und da gibt es eben halt solche Setups,
solche Betriebsszenarien, so nennen wir die,
wo man dann feststellt, das hat man halt über sehr unruhige Bedingungen,
hat man sozusagen schlechtes Wetter.
Und dann kann man sich auch überlegen, nee, da gehe ich lieber nicht mehr hin.
Also erstmal alles richtig machen.
Also vermeiden. Das heißt, man tastet so den gesamten Operationsraum mal ab,
wo sind eigentlich die guten Ecken.
Und die sind auch nicht so Gott gegeben, die liegen nicht so auf dem Tisch,
dass man die schon vorher weiß. So ist das nicht.
Aus guter Theorie hat man Vorhersagen. Die sagen, ja, da wird es wackelig, da ist es stabiler.
Das stimmt sehr oft, trotzdem muss man das alles abtasten danach.
Und das heißt, das ist im Prinzip dann so die Vermeidung von Ärger.
Das ist die allerniedrigste Ebene.
Aber auch schon sehr wichtig, dass man ein Operationsregime rausfindet,
wo man sagt, okay, also bei dem Magnetfeld, bei der Heizleistung,
wenn ich das so mache und so mache, dann wird es gut.
Und das ist auch Fleißarbeit, da den Operationsraum zu durchmustern.
Man muss eben sehr gut beobachten. und das mit Theorie und Simulation immer
wieder auch abchecken, ob man das dann auch so verstanden hat,
warum das so ist, weil ansonsten kann das durchaus auch eine Fehlinformation sein.
So, wenn man sich jetzt in etwa instabile Regime begeben muss,
weil die andere günstige Bedingungen oder günstige Eigenschaften haben,
sagt, naja, nehmen wir mal so als Beispiel, da habe ich besonders hohe Temperaturen.
Aber das ist nicht so furchtbar stabil. Dann fängt man an, mit Regelungsmethoden da etwas zu machen.
Und da gibt es eben das Feed-Forward und das Feedback.
Feed-Forward ist, dass man irgendeinen Aktuator hat, also irgendeinen Einfluss
nehmen kann, der dann diese Instabilität stabil macht, der das so ausregelt.
Dass man sozusagen wirklich aktiv einfach steuert.
Wenn ich dabei so selber so sage.
Vorausschauen, sodass man gar nicht erst in die kritischen Bereiche.
Ja, oder dass man es ausgedämpft kriegt, dass man es dann so unter Kontrolle
kriegt, dass man dagegen steuert. Das ist so feedforward.
Man regelt dagegen, aber so nicht aktiv nach vorne, weil man weiß, was man tut.
Womit kann man dann regeln? Also
was könnte das für ein, das ist jetzt der Gaszufluss oder Wärmezufluss?
Das ist zum Beispiel eine Regelgröße. Man kann auch gezielt geringe Mengen von,
Nichtwasserstoffgasen einleiten.
Das ist ganz schick. Damit kann man so Strahlung erzeugen, also elektromagnetische
Strahlung, Licht kann man damit so ganz gezielt in bestimmten Bereichen erzeugen,
die dann das Plasma sozusagen beruhigen oder die Prozesse am Rand dann eben halt beruhigen.
Nicht nur damit es gut aussieht, sondern damit man etwa unerwünschte Wandbelastungen reduzieren kann.
Das ist etwa so eine ganz wichtige Regelgröße, die haben wir jetzt gerade ganz
gut in den Griff bekommen, solchen Strahlungsgürtel so mit einem Fremdgas zu
erzeugen, sodass uns die Wand nicht so heiß wird.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, so eine Art Instabilität, da hat man plötzlich einfach Überhitzung der Wand.
Mist, dann kann man das so natürlich nicht betreiben, aber wenn man diesen Strahlungsgürtel
erzeugt, dann kann man das so betreiben.
Dann bildet die Heizung selber natürlich eine Regelgröße, das heißt also an
der kann man regeln, also wie stark und wo.
Den Gaseinlass oder wenn es eben halt kein Gas ist, haben wir auch andere Instrumente,
um neutrale Wasserstoffatome dort hineinzubringen.
Das geht über so kleine gefrorene Wasserstoffpillen. Die kann man dort einschießen
und da diskutieren wir gerade, wie wir das geregelt machen, wie wir das aktiv geregelt machen.
Wenn man es dann richtig gut im Griff hat, etwa bei diesem Strahlungsgürtel,
dann kann man das eben halt in Feedback packen.
Das heißt also im Prinzip beobachtet man dann das Plasma, wackelt das oder ist
das jetzt nicht da, wo ich es haben möchte und dann habe ich einen Aktuator, also einen Einfluss,
ein Fremdgas, was ich dort an einer ganz bestimmten Stelle sehr kontrolliert
einleite, einer ganz bestimmten Menge und das führt dann wiederum,
dass diese Information, die ich dann darüber habe, dass die mir sagt,
jetzt ist gut und das packt man dann in solche automatischen Schleifen rein.
Kann man in das Magnetfeld auch beeinflussen?
Ja, ist aber ein bisschen träge. Also für schnelle Regelungen ist das gar nicht
gut, weil so ein Magneten kann man nicht auf kurzen Zeitskalen hoch und runter fahren.
Aber es gibt auch glaube ich zusätzlich zu den Hauptmagneten gibt es noch so
zusätzliche Magneten, die nochmal so dann...
Ja, wir haben 20 Magneten, die alleine für solche Veränderungen des Magnetfeldes
da sind und auch das, da haben sie ja schon recht, auch das kann man in solche
Regelkreise reinpacken, allemal feed forward.
Also das ist auch wieder so, das sind Magnetfeldkonfigurationen,
das heißt also Also dann sagen wir, naja, das ist nicht gut,
jetzt schieben wir das noch ein bisschen und dann ist es wieder gut.
Aber auch das ist im Prinzip denkbar ein Feedback, aber das ist eine langsame Regelung.
Alles was mit Magneten selber zu tun hat, hat auch so seine zeitliche Einschränkungen.
Das ist einfach von der Physik der Magneten gegeben, also von der Induktion der Spulen.
Also das ganze System ist im Prinzip so ein großphysikalischer Eierlauf, kann man sagen.
Es ist schon ein Jonglieren, ja.
Man muss schon alles austarieren. Man hat erstmal diese Maschine gebaut,
man ist in der Lage, dieses Plasma zu erzeugen.
Nur das zu erzeugen allein reicht nicht. Man muss diverse Kriterien jetzt sicherstellen,
um Turbulenzen, Temperaturverhalten etc., also um sozusagen die idealen Voraussetzungen zu schaffen,
um dann künftig auch eine Fusion kontrolliert und in dem Parameterrahmen,
den man haben will, in dem Effizienzrahmen vor allem, den man haben will,
ablaufen lassen. lassen zu können.
Und das ist sozusagen der Stand der Forschung, den man jetzt erreicht hat.
Wie sieht denn jetzt die nächste Entwicklungsstufe aus? Wo befinden wir uns sozusagen?
Was wird jetzt als nächstes umgesetzt werden?
Wie nah sind wir sozusagen auch an
diesem Punkt, wo es dann mit wirklichen Fusionsexperimenten begonnen wird?
Na zunächst erstmal vorab gesagt, richtige Fusionsexperimente werden wir hier nie machen.
Nie machen?
Nein, wir werden hier nie Deuterium und Tritium in die Maschine einleiten.
Der Grund ist ganz banal, die ist zu
klein. Wir sprachen über das Volumen-zu-Oberfläche-Verhältnis. Sprich...
Ist aber jetzt kein kleiner Apparat. Ich war da, also...
Für ein Fusionskraftwerk ist das schon noch eine Mini-Version.
Aber wir reden bei Fusionskraftwerken von Gigawatt-Kraftwerken.
Das sind wirkliche Großanlagen.
Ja, wie viel größer als das, was jetzt hier aufgebaut ist, müsste ein entsprechendes System sein?
Wenn man konservativ rechnet, also wenn wir im Prinzip diese Maschine einfach
physikalisch-technisch fortsetzen, wir reden da von Skalierung,
dann landen wir ohne weiteres im 1000 Kubikmeter Plasma-Volumenbereich.
Wir haben jetzt 30 Kubikmeter, also von 30 auf 1000.
Was würde sich dann sozusagen auf diesen Durchmesser des Turos so?
Sowas wie 45 Meter. Okay. Also es ist eine große Anlage, es ist aber auch keine bizarr große Anlage.
Also wenn sie mal in so einem Gigawatt Braunkohlekraftwerk gewesen sind,
das sind auch große Kessel mit diesen zig Meter hoch und wirklich sehr, sehr beeindruckend.
Also ein Gigawatt braucht auch einfach große technische Anlagen.
Das ist ja erstmal nichts Besonderes, das ist nicht außerhalb der Skala draußen,
sondern es ist einfach ein ganz normales Großkraftwerk. Für ein Großkraftwerk
ist das Ding viel zu klein.
Diese 30 Kubikmeter, die sind im Hinblick auf das Verhältnis zwischen dem Volumen
zu der Oberfläche so ungünstig,
dass wir gar nicht diese Temperaturen, diese 100 Millionen Grad damit erreichen können.
Als Folge ist es natürlich auch nutzlos, dort Tritium reinzutun.
Das würde so wenig fusionieren, man würde nichts daraus lernen und wir müssten
die ganze Anlage als nukleare Anlage trotzdem betreiben, weil wir mit Tritium
umgehen, das ist dann auch ein radioaktives Element und das wäre dann plötzlich alles nuklear.
Und das ist kein Mehrwert, wenn man nichts daraus lernt und eben halt nur die Umstände hat.
Das wäre rein symbolisch und das ist wissenschaftlich und auch technologisch nutzlos.
In dem Sinne, das ist kein Fusionsexperiment, sondern das ist zunächst erstmal eine Anlage,
um herauszufinden, ist dieses Magnetfeld jetzt in der Lage, die Wärmeisolation,
auf der ich immer wieder rumreite, diese Wärmeisolation herzustellen unter stabilen,
kontrollierten, geregelten Bedingungen, die es braucht.
Um in einer größeren Anlage dann Fusion zu machen.
Aber das ist genau die Strategie. Man könnte natürlich jetzt einen Schuss ins
Blaue machen, gleich eine große Anlage bauen.
Aber da wir noch nicht gut genug wissen, ob diese große Anlage,
mit der man gleich Fusion machen könnte,
ob die das auch wirklich liefert, baut man aus rein ökonomischen Gründen das
natürlich erst mal als kleine Anlage, die noch keine Fusion macht,
wo man sagen kann, so jetzt haben wir alles beisammen,
dass wir diesen großen Wurf machen können.
Das ist letztlich eine Risikoreduktion, also Investitionsrisikoreduktion.
Denn es wäre nicht auszuschließen, dass man eine Großanlage baut und die läuft nicht gut.
Die liefert einfach nicht genug. Das ist ein Mistkraftwerk.
Und man will ja die Basis dafür herstellen, dass man weiß, was man tut,
dass man dann gleich bei dieser ersten Generation, bei der ersten ihrer Art,
dass man dort gleich ein funktionstüchtiges Kraftwerk auf die Beine stellt.
Ja.
Trotzdem ist ja der Stellarator, also auch wenn jetzt nur Japan und Deutschland
dieses Modell bisher verfolgen,
schon auch ein realer Kandidat für eine mögliche Umsetzung als echtes Fusionskraftwerk.
Was sind sozusagen die Vorteile und warum man jetzt bei diesem System auch geblieben
ist oder dieses Konzept weiterverfolgt hat,
wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen eine Umsetzung vorstellt, was macht diesen Ansatz geeignet dafür,
wirklich letzten Endes die Basis für eine Fusionsenergiegewinnung zu sein?
Zunächst muss ich korrigieren, es ist nicht nur Japan und Deutschland.
Das waren so in der historischen Entwicklung so diejenigen großen Labors,
die da richtig am Ball geblieben sind.
Es gibt etliche etwas kleinere, die teilweise auch durchgehend mitgespielt haben,
die wieder eingestiegen sind.
Also wir haben schon Stellaratoren in allen Nationen.
Also China baut gerade einen Stellarator. In den USA gibt es mehr Stellaratoren.
Es gibt ein wichtiges Experiment in Spanien.
Also so klein ist die Szene dann doch wieder nicht.
Also wir haben da schon eine ganz gute Stellarator-Familie insgesamt.
Die könnte natürlich immer größer sein, weil dadurch mehr Kraft entsteht da
drin. Also einfach auch mehr Innovationskraft.
Aber auch die anderen sind alle mehr oder weniger auf demselben Stand.
Naja, das sind unterschiedlich große Maschinen. Größte spielt immer eine Rolle.
Die sind auch von unterschiedlichen Entwicklungsstadiumen, also unterschiedliche Generationen da drin.
Also der Wendelstein ist schon die größte und vor allem die am weitesten fortgeschrittene
Anlage also die mit großem Abstand modernste und leistungsfähigste Anlage da
ist jetzt so im Prinzip das ganze Wissen,
der Welt, der Stellarator-Welt und der letzten Dekaden da reingeflossen und
da ist alles mal zusammengebündelt.
Warum ist der Stellarator jetzt eigentlich ein guter Kandidat?
Naja, wenn man jetzt einmal wieder zurück geht zur Physik.
Dieser berühmte Strom im Plasma, der beim Tokamak ja erforderlich ist und der
auch ein Vorteil ist, weil der Strom das Plasma auch heizt.
Das war ursprünglich mal ein ganz großer Pluspunkt beim Tokamak,
als das die dominante Heizung war.
Aber dieser Strom, den kriegt man ja dann nicht raus, der muss da gemacht werden.
Und der hat schon auch seine Nachteile. Er macht das Plasma instabil,
also diesen elektrischen Strom mag das Plasma gar nicht so gerne.
Wir sprachen über diese dynamischen Phänomene da drin, dass das Plasma seine
eigene Dynamik entwickelt.
Und die kann dazu führen, dass das Plasma auch einfach sich mal verabschiedet
innerhalb von sehr kurzer Zeit.
Und dann wird dieser Strom, und wir reden bei dem Strom in einem Tokamak von
Megaampere, von Millionenampere, wird dann sehr plötzlich unterbrochen.
Und das ist ein sehr unangenehmes Event.
Das heißt also, dann wird die ganze Maschine ordentlich durchgeschüttelt und
muss inspiziert werden. und das ist kein gutes Betriebsszenario,
das ist ein Kopfschmerz. Das gibt es beim Stellarator nicht.
Der Stellarator hat ja keinen Strom, der braucht keinen Strom,
weil man die ganze Magnetfeldformung in die Magnete reingesteckt hat.
Das ist ein Riesenvorteil, die Stromlosigkeit des Fusionsplasmas.
Hört sich so ein bisschen nischig an.
Nicht so, man sagt halt Stromlosigkeit des Fusionsplasmas, aber das ist schon
ein dickes Ding. Also ein stromloses Plasma ist per se, per Definition viel stabiler.
Wo kein Strom drin ist, kann auch kein Strom abbrechen.
Wir brauchen keinen Strom da drin. Das heißt, in anderen Worten,
das Magnetfeld, was wir mit diesen externen Magneten generieren,
ist für sich dieses immaterielle Gefäß, in das man das Plasma reinfüllt und
es bleibt da drin sitzen, bis man es wieder rausnimmt.
Und das ist der zweite wichtige Aspekt.
Das Stellarator-Plasma, das Stellarator-Fusions-Plasma, das füllt man in dieses
Magnetfeld rein und im idealen Fall hockt das da drin.
Und das bedeutet, dieses Kraftwerk läuft auch einfach stundenlang,
den ganzen Tag, wochenlang.
Das ist eine ganz stabile Angelegenheit. Das ist in diesem Gefäß drin.
Man hat immer den Gaseinlass, man hat die Pumpen und das Plasma arbeitet dort wie so ein Gasöfchen.
Das ist ein zweiter Aspekt, der einem beim Tokamak Sorgen macht.
Diesen Strom, der ist ja nicht von selber im Plasma, den muss man dort hineinbringen.
Und wenn man etwa den Tokamak ITER in Südfrankreich nimmt, dafür braucht man
einen gewaltigen Magneten noch in der Mitte, also eine so große Spule noch in
der Mitte, diesen Strom in das Plasma induziert.
Diese Induktion erfordert, dass man diesen Magneten in der Mitte hochfährt und wieder runterfährt.
Und das passiert nicht innerhalb von einer Sekunde oder Bruchteil einer Sekunde,
sondern über Minuten oder gar Stunden kann das passieren.
Ist aber eine zusätzliche Komplikation, weil man dadurch so Zyklen reinbekommt,
dieses Hochfahren, Runterfahren, Hochfahren, Runterfahren.
Und das ist technisch problematischer, wenn man es eben im Vergleich zu einfach
einem Magnetfeld, was das Plasma einfach aufbewahrt, wo man gar nichts machen muss.
Also das heißt, es gibt da so Plus und Minus. Der Druckermark ist nach wie vor
immer noch die leistungsfähigste Fusionsmaschine, die mit ihren Betriebsparametern,
mit diesen Plasmaparametern am nächsten an die Fusion rangekommen ist.
Also hat immer noch so die Nase vorne. Der Stellarator robbt sich da jetzt so
langsam ran an diese Werte.
Und die Entwicklung sieht ganz gut aus.
Wenn man mit dem Steuerator auf solide Füße gestellt, die gleichen Güteparameter
für das Plasma erzeugt wie in einem Tokamak, ist der Steuerator gewiss besser.
Also man kann die stationär betreiben, also am Dauerstrich, im Dauerbetrieb
betreiben und er ist stabil.
Das ist beides für ein Kraftverbot.
Verstehe. Trotzdem ist ja auch, glaube ich, der Stellarator durchaus bestimmten
mechanischen Kräften auch ausgesetzt.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass diese ganzen Magnete da in so einer verbogenen
Form drumherum liegen, die dürften ja wahrscheinlich auch einen gewissen Stress
auf das ganze System ausüben.
Haben die nicht die Tendenz dazu, sich wieder gerade biegen zu wollen? Wie hört sich das aus?
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt und das kann man sagen, das ist so eine Schwäche
des Stellerators. Nichts im Leben ist perfekt.
Jeder hat Stärken und Schwächen. Eine Schwäche des Stellarators besteht daran,
dass die Kräfteverteilung, die von diesen Magneten impliziert wird,
die resultiert aus der Form dieser Magnete, dass die sehr komplex ist.
Simpel gesprochen kann man sagen, diese nicht planaren Magnete,
diese geformten Magnete, sobald sie vom Strom durchflossen sind,
wollen sie eben werden und wollen sie rund werden und entsprechend bilden sich die Kräfte aus.
Das heißt, sie versuchen sich in diese einfache Form selber zu bringen,
weil sie müssen in diese nicht ebene Form hinein gezwungen werden mit Stahlgehäusen
und das geht dann über die Stahlgehäuse, geht das in die Schrauben,
in die Stützstrukturen.
Das heißt, die ganze mechanische Struktur muss erstens recht hohe Kräfte aushalten.
Also hier beim Wendelstein sind das sowas wie 100 Megapaskal,
um das mal so zu illustrieren.
Das ist so wie eine Tonne auf einem Quadratzentimeter.
Also so ein Auto auf einem Quadratzentimeter sitzen.
Bei Fusionsmaschinen, die nochmal stärkeres Magnetfeld brauchen,
ist es entsprechend nochmal mehr.
Da hat man nochmal so einen Faktor 3, 4, 5, teilweise sogar 8 mehr,
je nachdem wie stark man das Magnetfeld macht.
Und das geht alles schon arg an die technischen Grenzen, was so Stähle eigentlich
noch mögen, was Stähle also ertragen können.
Das heißt also, man hat dort durchaus eine Maschinenbauaufgabe,
die nicht vom Pappe ist. um mit diesen starken Kräften klar zu kommen.
Starke Magnete, wir haben Sprachen davon, je stärker das Magnetfeld,
desto besser die Wärmeisolation.
Und diese starken Magnetfelder erzeugen einfach auch starke Kräfte.
Und diese starken Kräfte müssen von einer starken Stahlstruktur,
Stützstrukturen und Haltestrukturen abgefangen werden.
Und da kommt man an die Materialgrenzen von Stahl ran.
Da geht man so an die Extreme. Also ist technisch durchaus machbar,
Aber man legt da schon ganz gut die Ohren an.
Ja, das haben wir, glaube ich, den Stille Rathor ganz gut beschrieben, auch das Potenzial.
Es ist klar, hier ist noch ein längerer Weg zu gehen.
Ganze Energiegewinnung kriegt natürlich
derzeit extreme Dynamik durch die Verbilligung von Solarstrom etc.
Also ich denke, wir sind gerade mitten in einer technischen Wende.
Dadurch, dass Batterien so günstig werden und Strom und Wind jetzt auf einmal
sozusagen ihrer Nachteile beraubt werden.
Von daher glaube ich, ist es ein bisschen offen, welche Lösung jetzt die Fusionstechnik
uns noch anbieten wird in der Zukunft.
Kann man das so sagen, dass es ein bisschen Ungewissheit hat?
Ungewissheit gibt es ja immer ich werde aber nicht so nicht so vorsichtig ich
bin der Bezeugung, wir werden die Fusion schon brauchen ähm,
Letztlich ist das eine Primärenergiequelle, die wir noch gar nicht nutzen.
Und warum sollten wir die einfach nicht nutzen?
Wie stark wir sie nutzen und in welchen Segmenten wir nutzen,
das ist eine andere Frage.
Fakt ist ja, wir sprachen schon darüber, dass das Großkraftwerke der Gigawatt-Klasse sind.
Und man kann natürlich diese Gigawatt
auch einsammeln über viele einzelne Megawatt oder 5 oder 10 Megawatt.
So 100 mal 10 Megawatt ist auch ein Gigawatt.
Dafür braucht man aber natürlich schon massive Netze. Man muss Energie transportieren,
gegebenenfalls auch über große Strecken, weil auch 100 mal 10 Megawatt und 10
Megawatt Windkraftwerke sind schon massiv. Das gleiche gilt auch für Solar.
Man hat schon hohen Flächenverbrauch. Das heißt, man muss aus der Fläche das
zusammenziehen und transportieren und dann an den Ort zu bringen,
wo man auch mal ein Gigawatt braucht.
Das heißt also, wo man hochkonzentriert viel Energie braucht und zuverlässig
braucht, also wirklich 24-7 am besten, also ohne Speicher, dass es einfach so liefert.
Da ist die Fusion schon ganz gut.
Also so für Schwerindustrien, Stahlproduktion, solche Sachen.
Große Industriekomplexe, große Agglomerationen, also Megastädte,
wie man das so nennen kann.
Wo Grundlast einfach so da ist, wo das auch einen Mehrwert darstellt,
wo man sich Blackouts auch nicht leisten kann.
Nur mal nebenbei gesagt, speichern hört sich immer so einfach an,
aber auch Energie speichern ist gar nicht ohne.
Das ist sehr teuer, das ist nach wie vor Batterieforschung, riesen Forschungsgebiet.
Die Batterien, die wir gewohnt sind, sind eben halt von der Telefonbatterie
bis zur Autobatterie, also von Elektromobilität.
Das ist ja alles so unsere Erlebniswelt, also sozusagen der Consumer-Bereich.
Aber wenn wir jetzt von Terrawattstunden-Batterien reden, das ist eine ganz
andere Liga für die Grundversorgung.
Also die großen globalen Schwankungen von Wind und Sonne, also der Sonnenzyklus
ist ganz offenkundig, der ist ja geometrisch gegeben, noch ein bisschen durch
Wetter gesteuert, der Windaspekt ist völlig durch Wetter gesteuert.
Und diese Schwankungen muss man ja durch Speichern ausgleichen.
Und das Problem ist wirklich nicht von Pappe.
Und das kombiniert sich mit der Transportaufgabe.
Also Energie speichern ist schwierig und Energie transportieren ist schwierig.
Da kann die Fusion ausspielen, dass sie erstens als große Energiequelle nicht
aus der Fläche transportiert werden muss und dass sie als ein Wärmekraftwerk
einfach verfügbar ist, die hohe Verfügbarkeit hat.
Und wo dieses Segment ist und wie groß das Segment ist, das hängt sehr von den
sozioökonomischen Bedingungen des jeweiligen Landes ab, wie stark es industrialisiert ist.
Ein viel ländlicheres Land ist da wahrscheinlich ganz anders aufgestellt als
ein hochindustrialisiertes Land.
Wie die Industrien sind, ob das eine starke chemische Industrie ist,
die braucht unendlich viel Prozesswärme.
Ob es dort Stahlindustrie gibt, ist auch an Energie, Stahlschmelzen oder sowas gewohnt.
Oder auch Fernwärmesysteme.
Und Fernwärmesysteme für große Cities, die auch einfach Basisversorgung brauchen
bis hin zu Verkehr, nicht U-Bahnen, Krankenhäusern und so weiter.
Das ist ein anderes Setup als eine ländliche Region.
Und ich glaube, da gilt auch wieder, es gibt keine Universallösung.
Also nicht ein Zauberstab, der dann gleich alles auflöst, sondern man muss ein neues System aufbauen.
Und in dieser systemischen Sicht, wie so ein Gesamtsystem sinnvoll und ökonomisch
leistungsfähig und den Bedürfnissen entsprechend aufgebaut ist,
das ist wiederum ein Thema,
was einerseits noch besser verstanden werden muss, was ich
aber auch jetzt wo wir sehen wie stark sich die welt verändert und
wie sich auch sozioökonomische bedingungen in jedem jedem land verändern
wo das auch diese so in entwicklung unter unterlegen ist insofern ist es ganz
schwer da jetzt so etwas in zahlen zu nennen oder das jetzt wirklich so rein
zu gießen wenn ich sagen würde da diese fusion macht alles oder die fusion macht
nur zehn prozent das ist alles bodenlos nächstes alles haltlos alleine,
Was wir machen müssen und was wir versuchen, oder beziehungsweise woran wir
arbeiten, ist, dass wir die technologische und physikalische Basis dafür herstellen,
dass man diese Option hat.
Denn wenn wir uns da nicht vorarbeiten, dann haben wir sie nicht,
wenn wir sie brauchen. Dann guckt man dumm.
Genau, Vorbereitszeit.
Jetzt hätten wir gerne Fusion. Wie Bäume pflanzen.
Wenn man Holz braucht, muss man 100 Jahre vorher einen Baum pflanzen. So ist das leider.
Ja, hier wird auf jeden Fall viel gepflanzt, das ist ganz offensichtlich und
ich denke auch jetzt rein über das Ziel hinaus, was man jetzt hier natürlich im Fokus hat,
dem Betrieb von einer Fusionsmaschine, fällt ja auch eine ganze Menge an sekundären
Forschungsergebnissen hier ab.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, es muss viel erfunden werden, es müssen neue Instrumente
erfunden werden, Beobachtungen der Prozesse, ich denke Materialforschung und
allein auch so Kühltechnik,
sind ja alles solche Bereiche, die hier von der Forschung auch profitieren.
Ja, ganz gewiss. Wie immer, wenn man sich an die technologischen Grenzgebiete
begibt und da landen wir automatisch im Hinblick auf Wärmebelastung,
Supraleitung, Kryotechnologie.
Wir arbeiten dort ganz oft an den technologischen Grenzen und eben auch die
Leistungsfähigkeit unserer Fusionsmaschine ist oftmals technologisch begrenzt.
Also nicht durch die Physik.
Es gibt keine Physikgründe, warum man dort nicht hinkommen sollte,
sondern es gibt ganz einfache technologische Gründe.
Das heißt, wir kratzen dort einfach an diesen technologischen Limits und das
erzeugt natürlich automatisch für sich Innovationskraft und immer wieder Suche nach neuen Lösungen.
Ja, super. Gutes Schlusswort. Ich bedanke mich für die Ausführung.
War mir ein Vergnügen.
Ja, das war's hier von Forschergeist zum Stellerator und dem Forschungsweg auf
dem Weg zur Gewinnung von Fusionenergie.
Ja, und dann würde ich sagen, vielen Dank, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's.
Bald geht's hier hoffentlich wieder weiter und ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.